I'm going to open the subcommittee work
session starting with uh House Bill 1286
uh take them in the order of what I'm
hoping will be uh quickest and go on
from
there and so the first thing anybody in
the subcommittee
have thoughts on this I at least 1286
that's the emerging land surveyors and
the Board of Professional Engineers um
you know what I remember from the public
testimony is that the the boorder of
land surveyors doesn't have a whole lot
to do they don't get a lot of
complaints um and actually if uh
director Courtney if you could come up
and you know confirm you know how what
we heard is they don't have to meet very
often uh whereas the engineers meet more
often and what their the the land
surveyors don't know much about the
engineering stuff and so it's not clear
this makes sense but that's what we're
trying to figure
out yeah Mr chair thank you Mr chair
repres Brown y good morning um I I
recall hearing that the the land
surveyors weren't overly concerned if
they were put together but the engineers
definitely were concerned about it
and yeah
there was some talk that if it was two
from each it would be okay but I don't
think that that's what the engineers
thought was a good idea so that's kind
of what I'm recalling yeah the question
there's two questions really one is do
they get merged and then if they do
what's the uh makeup of the board going
to be you know Mr chair yep a representa
of uh two two two points that I have on
my notes is one um the
Board of Professional Engineers can
handle overseeing land surveyors as long
as they're are
surveyors
but if you're trying to reduce the
board now and cutting down the members
on the board and that would add to the
engineers load on the board so they were
I mean I have 1 two 3 four five
opposition and no one single one came to
say support it so they were not opposed
to it but the fact that you're not only
trying to merge the two professions and
you're trying to reduce the board and
you're going to put the burden on uh the
engineers who are already a
volunteer yeah that was a big concern I
agree and also um as I recall the uh
there's a wide range of different
Specialties the engineers and losing
people means they're going to have less
of that but anyway your your take on uh
first of
all yeah any of the if you have any
views on this and then in particular
um if there's you know how busy is the
uh the land surveyor board and then the
usual thing is um you know are there any
particular other than the general kind
of antitrust concerns or anything like
that so thank you uh lindsy Courtney
executive director oplc um I think
that's a good summary of what we heard
at the hearing I would say that the land
surveyors board met six times last year
engineering met 11 neither board meets
very
long um the land surveyors had seven
complaints and FY 23 Engineers had three
so neither of those bodies receive a
significant number of
complaints and I will say that
you know some of the
data is not necessarily relevant in
light of the changes last session you
know a lot of the need for engineering
and land surveyors to meet had to do
with lure but they're no longer
reviewing applications so we at the
office anticipate that a lot of boards
including those two boards will actually
meet less frequently moving forward and
for um less amount of
time okay um
yeah I was going to
ask other than you know any discussion
of changes to rul making or if there's a
complaint that the investigation gets
the point where they you know there
needs to be some professional expertise
or a final decision um yeah what else is
changes you highlighted exactly the two
areas one is in ruem and then two has to
do with adjudicating cases that are
valid
if you were are viable and making
findings of fact and
sanctions okay and for the seven in one
case and three in the other of
complaints how many of them you know I
know it's just one year but how many of
them actually got to the point where the
board had to get
involved so that those cases were under
the prior statutory structure so they
they reviewed all the complaints I will
say that the all of the boards review
all complaints at some point because
only the board has authority to dispos
position a complaint so at some point
after an investigation they'll review
the report of Investigation conclude to
dismiss or proceed to hearing in those
instances none of them resulted in a
hearing okay um so kind of follow up on
that
so going forward um I know that the oplc
is going to do the
investigation um you know do they come
with some kind of recommendation the
board at least in some cases like like
if it's you know somebody's complaining
that they were charged too much or
whatever that's not really licensing it
I don't know if there are any of those
but yes that's what happened so during
the investigation of professional
expertise is required we either pull in
an expert that we've contracted with or
um you know for engineering and
surveying we don't have a lot of those
cases we'll probably recuse a board
member to act as an expert and then we
will make a recommendation in a report
of investigation and the board makes a
decision about what to do moving forward
and I know that there's a variety of
Subs Specialties among the
engineers
um well maybe I can ask if there is
there anyone here from um or wants to
speak about the um the board of
Engineers okay I don't see anybody
so I guess the question is um you know
even if we we go forward with the
merger the next issue that I heard I
think I remember complaints about was
that by reducing
um what's the current makeup of the
board I mean how many you know F because
it's not in the bill because it wasn't
it's a
replace I believe it's five but let me
confirm if it's five now it leaves it at
five but it um two surve surve engine
which means they would be taking uh to
the Engineers off if it's five currently
yes it's five currently one public
member for Professional
Engineers okay and they have a public
member and they'd be down to two
Professional Engineers and two landscape
surveyors
which um Mr chair yeah and Mr Brown and
then man py and as I said there
was from I I believe from the engineer
side there was a lot of discomfort with
that two engineers and two land
they I think
they thought the two land surveyor was
too many well
um I have a couple of questions to
director
Courtney uh one is the rule making from
the last years H how much have that been
implemented by
OPC and see any big gaps because of that
so we we've implemented all of the rules
that we've been required I should say we
have moved forward with the rul making
on all of the um rul making obligations
that we received last statutory or last
legislative session they're not all
complete um because of the
process
um The Challenge remains that the board
statutes continue to conflict with opl's
statutes and there continue to be rules
on the books that conflict with our
statutes obviously that's outside the
purview this but but that continues to
be our
challenge follow yeah so I think this is
going
to yeah there's other bills um that I
think are going to deal with that
including the non- amendment is coming
but my followup would be the engineers
on the board said you know they're
pretty efficient there is no issue with
the board having to meet
and very diligent and getting it done
very and the comment I remember that
stuck in my mind was we are Engineers we
are efficient we have the checklist and
we've go
through pretty uh quickly so is that the
experience that the oplc has or are you
stepping on each other's
toone no I don't think they um they're
not a board that takes a significant
administrative time I do want note um
because there were some comments
regarding Specialties you know
mechanical engineering versus chemical
that's not something that's under the
purview of Licensing and the board
composition currently does not
um that's not a criteria for being
appointed to the board so under the
current criteria you it could be all
Structural Engineers um and that would
not run a fall the statute if that's the
concern then maybe that needs to be
addressed statutorily but that was one
of the things that they talk we see that
in the medical board too right it's not
each specialty is not
represented that's not the idea it's the
general engineering that was not the
comment that I heard or in in having
one-on-one conversation or in the
testimony that that was a big
concern but the fact that the load by
shrinking the board the load load on the
volunteer board members is going to
increase reducing it from 5 to three or
72 it's going to be the same number of
members but they would replace two of
the four Engineers with two of the land
surveyors as I understand it yeah so
that was that was the big uh challenge
um I'd like to let uh representative
well actually if you have a brief
comment on this subject I was just going
to respond to what uh represent Manti
said yes the I I believe the Board of
engineers said if you do this it's going
to be more work for us okay um
representative Bailey and then Gould
just a question I guess is is there some
usual number of board members that we're
attempting to achieve
or I would say that seven five and seven
tend to be the ideal number um currently
seven I think is more common with um two
public members the public members Contin
to be the challenge for recruitment
which I think is why some of these
boards are proposed to be reduced to
five representative got followup Y and
if there if this was a larger board
could you more fully satisfy the
engineers certainly we have larger
boards I mean the Board of Nursing is 13
um Pharmacy is currently seven so that's
not something we we can't work
with uh representative gold
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question so I apologize I missed the
very beginning of the meeting you have
had uh seven complaints and three
complaints and which is which so three
for engineers seven for surveyors okay
so my question has to do with testimony
we heard regarding mergers that if we
were to merge the two boards
currently my dyslexia here the land
surveyors only had three Lance surveyors
had seven okay so the other group that
only had three would have to come in now
for 10 meetings to address three
complaints that affected their
profession I think she said that L the
land Ser surveying board actually met
six times and the engineers met 11 I
think
she no well there were two numbers no
but I'm telling her she was worried
about right correct me if I'm wrong but
I think think you're worried about him
they don't have to come in once per
complaint maybe no correct oftentimes
they're reviewing multiple multiple
complaints and it's not uncommon for
boards to you know wait for a meeting
until they have a couple complaints to
review we don't like that because we
like to move the complaints along but
that's very
common followup oh wait uh was that
representative G or yes yeah follow up
and then thank you representative G had
a followup and then man puty y thank you
Mr chair
so my concern is that when you have two
boards and the demands on their review
are different that merging them you know
the people who serve on these boards are
serving voluntarily and they're taking a
day off from earning a salary in order
to do so so if we're going to increase
the demands on a board that's currently
functioning in order to meet some goal
of
merger
I I need to understand why we would want
to increase the demand on a volunteer
who's giving up pay and will have to
deal with issues from an a profession
they are not a part
of so again I'm not taking a position on
this bill the agency is not and I want
to be sensitive to the fact that these
are volunteers that said I would see
these boards they don't spend a lot of
time um in meetings and doing board work
compared to other boards I do not
anticipate a significant increase in
time
um because the majority of their time in
the last year has been spent on lure
which they're not going to be
doing U thank you represent Mantra thank
you Mr chair so the other uh topic or
the uh discussion during the public
hearing was that with the housing need
the in increase of number of housing
projects in the state increasing
there'll be more demand for surveyors
and
Engineers uh and and also the safety
issue of uh Housing Development um I
don't know if it was public hearing or
one-on-one conversation that might put
more Demand on the board and the
engineers said we don't have problem
with doing the work but if you have to
take a whole day to come and uh testify
and follow what's happening at the
legislation things are changing that
takes away a whole day for us not doing
the board work but then also not doing a
work so that was another concern with
the boom you know but that's I don't
think that's related to what we do with
their board it's related to people
putting bills in which is completely
separate no no no but the thing is the
board was uh saying we have to show up
to uh the board members uh from
the engineering board and land surveyors
board to say we have to be at the
hearing we have to make sure we give
our the oh the hearing in public hearing
at
the that's question I mean isn't there
something published on what the meetings
if there's going to be um hearings on
complaints or something the board's
that's an no noticed ahead of time yes
yeah yes no I'm not talking about the
complaints to the board from the
professional complaints but if there are
bills related like this bill was here
and they spent two days to be here I
understand that but I don't see how that
has anything to how anything we do with
this bill is going to have any impact on
that I I'm maybe I'm missing something
but okay let me see how I can put
it it's all very clear in my mind but
I'm obviously not making any sense to
everybody else um the two points that
the engineer board the board member I
believe David Gil Board of Professional
Engineers and I I don't want to name f
you know just just what the issue is so
the what the issue was that the board
members were saying now with the
increased two points one is with the
increased demand for housing and
construction and structure there's a
demand for lancers and the engineers to
work long hours because we need that and
adding to that if you're going to add
more responsibility to the board members
professional board members that's going
to take time uh and the third was if the
board members have to show up for public
hearing at you know know that's another
day that they have to take away from
their paid position so now these were
the three concerns that I heard okay I
mean uh representative
Brown do you want to say something first
to you no I'll let you maybe you can
thank you um looking at the person
you're speaking of my notes from that
person uh said the board of Engineers
weren't in favor because of the workload
they're all volunteers and they get 40
applications per month but that is no
longer the case they get no applications
now is that right they re they don't
review applications up front at all
correct there's a bit of a transition
here because as you might expect there's
a um some boards are not thrilled with
the fact that the legislation
transferred that authority to the office
and I would say Engineers is one of them
um and they do contain some subjective
requirements in their roles so that has
made it um challenging but they are not
supposed to be reviewing
applications so thank you so to follow
up on that as as this morphs into
eventually what it's supposed to
be their workload should be decreased
which was the intent of this and become
more efficient in the in the short term
hopefully so
um and they and and that person also
said if they lose two Engineers that
will be they'll have to take more time
per meeting to review those applications
but that doesn't appear to be really a
valid point no or if they don't review
applications what I'll say
U right and you know we can if we decide
to go forward with merger we can we can
do something different than what this
says for the board size I mean we could
leave four engineers and add to land
surveyor
I um okay so it sounds like my my take I
um at least to summarize and people
could tell me if if I'm wrong that they
are probably going to have
um less work to do than they do now and
maybe they'll have to be involved in
some rul making to fix the discrepancies
but certainly once that done it should
be even less representative Gould or
thank you Mr chair I was going to write
it down so I wouldn't forget
it
um
so what I'm hearing in this regarding
this bill and I think it goes beyond
this bill to other similar bills we're
looking at is that there's been a lot of
change
and we're asking people to get their
heads around a lot of change and some
are struggling more than others and the
engineers specifically related to this
bill are struggling with the changes
that have already happened and are not
fully implemented in some
cases or it's not enough that it's
gotten to their experiential level and
it's part of their Consciousness and I'm
wondering with the conversation we had
recent this earlier this week about the
oversight committee taking on some of
the Board review
responsibilities if it wouldn't be
better to hold off on this and wait to
hear from the oversight committee what
their opinion is of the best way to move
forward which would also give all of
these boards especially these two boards
an opportunity to adjust to the changes
pretty drastic changes that were made in
the past
year representative M py yeah I totally
agree with uh representative gold in
terms of trying to change too many
things one on top of the
other my concern would be we might lose
very good volunteer board members I know
you know we have Workforce shortage and
all that but this is also part of
losing volunteer board members who are
very uh helpful and not kind
of make that Hasty not I shouldn't say
Hasty but uh quick decision one on top
of the other yeah okay uh so um like to
move on to the others I my I'll give my
view and then everybody can and then I
I'll look for a motion actually um I you
know but I don't oh and actually was are
you from the land surveyors yeah if you
want to speak
first no up at the mic I found out this
is actually showing up on YouTube so uh
that's what I was told I haven't looked
but please take a seat and introduce
yourself
and appreciate the opportunity chairman
leakas Simon Thompson I'm with Sheen
finny Capital group uh and we uh I
represent the New Hampshire land
surveyors Association I don't uh
disagree with a lot that's been said I
just feel the focus has been on the
engineers and that's obvious there's a
lot more of them um just wanted to
remind the members of of our position
that was stated at the hearing is that
we oppose the bill um if this bill were
to move forward um we would just want to
maintain more representation of land
surveyors it doesn't mean it has to be
equal to Engineers but if the current
makeup is five and that's hard and fast
and you did three Engineers to one
surveyor we would be adamantly opposed
to that the current bill is two
Engineers two land surveyors and one
public member right which that would
again we're opposed to the bill but if
that's what moves forward we could be
comfortable with that uh it's just if
you were to change that makeup to
311 three being engineers and one being
one surveyor there could be an
opportunity where you could have a quum
for a meeting and there not be a
surveyor there so that that was just
wanted to remind folks of what I was
thinking we haven't made any decision I
haven't heard from anyone else but I was
thinking if we were going to continue
with the merger that um the keep with
the 4 Engineers today two land surveyors
and a public
member um yes and that would raise it to
seven which is not a problem I don't
think so yep uh I know you're oppos the
bill but there there's a wider range of
Specialties and engineers and all that
but absolutely but thank you for that y
that input thank you for the opportunity
oh wait uh representative Brown thank
you Mr chair very quickly uh what's your
opposition because I'm trying
to probably is in my notes but if you I
mean if if you go back and and I was
trying to pull up my notes and I
couldn't find them either but is if my
mem Sur correct there was not one person
that testified in support of the bill
everybody that testified was opposed to
the bill um and again the land surveyor
both the chair of the board and the uh
chair of my
Association testified in opposition to
the bill but again with the same thought
that I had that I'm relaying to you now
is that if there if this bill were to
move forward the current makeup is okay
and if it were to change to what
chairman leas recommended they could be
comfortable with that so I guess the the
question then is what is the um the main
reason for the
opposition like if there just summarize
just briefly what are the real concerns
the main the main reason for the
opposition is they similar to the
engineers feel that the way they have
operated has worked well um there's very
specific land use laws to land surveyors
that while Engineers have some
understanding that's not their specialty
so those were the two main reasons for
the opposition okay um before I'll let
people speak but I want to hopefully we
can come to a uh a decision uh quite
soon and well I think this could work
and I would support it although I'd
probably suggest changing the board
makeup if we did that I'm also I don't
see that the there's a a large benefit
to doing it and and you can take a seat
that's thank you appreciate it um large
benit to to actually passing this to
doing the merger and um and I take rep
representative G's point that uh we've
already shaken things up and um you know
it might make sense to to let it settle
down before I mean some of these bills I
would have preferred if they came in
next year um
so people going to have a say I'd like
to keep the conversation brief because
we do have the two other bills one of
which is going to be a big deal longer
all right um represent G briefly yes
thank you just a procedural question Mr
chair if we if we were to recommend
interim study remind me what that means
does that give us the year to look at
this so I'll
um you know if the options were between
let's say interim study and itl okay the
difference is that um
if we do interim study it has two
effects we can actually meet to study
the bill and we have on some and
actually you know solve some problems
and accomplish good things by studying
it interim study has traditionally also
be been used as sort of a a polite kill
because where there's not really an
intent to do much in studying it the
other advantage of interim study over
itail or effect it could see as an
advantage or not is that if we do that
then something on this subject could be
you know added to an amendment in the
house or the Senate could do something
but if we itl it then at least for this
year that can't be considered okay are
you ready to entertain a motion uh does
anybody else need to well actually we
can do a motion then we can have a
discussion so yes I am I move that we
itl on this
bill okay and is there a second well
I'll second it for the sake of
conversation I'm sorry I'll second that
for the sake of discussion oh okay uh
discussion on the motion of itl I think
that's a good idea I would back that
because whether we are doing interim
study or itl it's putting a pause for
this year so that the changes that was
implemented made actually what I should
have done is is let representative goul
speak to her motion sorry first and then
representative Brown if he wants to
that's okay I was being
patient but
um I really feel
that given all the things in the
discussion that it's better off to just
kill this for right now let's give the
oversight committee time to do their
well let's see where that goes and give
them time to do their work let's give
the board's time to adjust and a new
bill can always be brought
up uh representative Brown do you have
anything uh thank you Mr chair
so originally intent of all of these
coming down from the governor's office
um is to to make our process more
efficient and to make it as Fair as
possible for people coming in from the
outside to try to get license in New
Hampshire and I think that's very
reasonable um because there there are
certainly we we've heard some
conversations about it's a little bit
restrictive to get a license or some of
the some of the processes so that I
think that's the intent of a lot of
these bills is to try to be more fair
and to be uh make the process quicker
and I think that's a good thing and
certainly the The Institute of Justice
when they here testifying uh the week
before last the gentleman from there had
really good points regarding that um so
I think that's kind of the intent so I
don't know that we want to
necessarily uh uh put it itail it at
this point although I I I certainly
think that now I'm going to say the
other side of my own conversation that
letting the does settle may not be a bad
idea
overall um and there's a lot more in
here that we haven't discussed that's
not just about the makeup of the board
also um so uh I'm I'm kind of on the
fence about what to do with this and I
would ask one more question of either
yourself or or the oplc folks we talked
about the
oversight committee but it if I
understood our conversation from the
other day the oversight committee's job
is not to
assess that oplc is managing the boards
correctly but it's a different test I
can I can speak to that I'm on it chair
McGuire and I are on that uh Senator
Carson's the uh the chair of it um it
isn't specific um the oversight
committee
can uh sort of you know take a wide
ranging thing now it's it's going to be
driven to some extent by um Senator
Carson the chair's vision of it and it's
only had two meetings one was
organizational and the way it seems to
be going is
to
um you know get a report on what's going
on especially after last year with the
ru making how that's progressing and
then people who are licensed who have
issues with oplc not going to get into
adjudicating particular complaints but
if there's General problems then um you
know we we listen to that and and and
you know oplc gets to hear that and they
get to respond about what's going on and
you know if there's a real problem
identified and there's something going
to be done about it then in later
meetings we can follow up on whether
that happened but there's nothing I
don't believe there's anything in the
duties of that committee that says they
can't take a look at anything and then
recommend legislation so um and and
although it's not a done deal what the
amendment that represent grto was
considering or suggested at the last
exec session was to add the duties that
were in
1676 to the oplc oversight committee I
believe she had an I mean that's not
what we're dealing with today but she
had an initial discussion with Senator
Carson and it looks like
uh Senator might be okay with it so and
I wanted that first I didn't want to be
involved in dumping a whole bunch of
work on her which she blindsiding her
but so anyway I don't know where that's
going to go it might might not um all
right representa
MTI yeah to just two quick points one
is on 20
1286 not a single
support for this Merchant number two is
I think it's making more and more sense
for the oplc oversight committee to see
how the process shift in process shift
in Minds set is happening and instead of
putting another change I think just
giving it a pause let it take and bring
in a new hopefully another whole year of
things would have gone through I think
makees sense R Brown thank you Mr chair
one more so following up on what I said
about making the licensing process more
fair and possibly easier especially
where we're short
Workforce uh for oplc
as we now stand with where we uh right
now that should have happened to some
degree is that accurate so the way it's
changed you're handing applications that
should make it sowhat easier for people
coming in as opposed to the board
process and if that's the case well go
ahead and let you answer that yes thank
you for I would say for the majority
large majority of boards that has
changed for certain few boards
um it's been a bit of a transition
because it has represented a significant
culture
shift and we're trying to work
collaboratively um but it it can be
challenging you have something to
add I think I think so Douglas so oplc
general counsel also in 655 it's
important to remember there was a clause
in that bill that said the current rule
structure stays in place until those
bills are or the rules are replaced or
they expire naturally so some of that
transition is just we're working with
the old system until the new system goes
through the Jael car process so it's
there's a little bit of that to consider
as well and is there I'm assuming the
rules aren't expiring soon is there some
process to push for that to be
done changing the rules yes um so
we're so I can't speak publicly about
some of of our initiatives because it's
it involves Contracting um but we are
working on an initiative that would
bring an additional support to assist
the boards with rulemaking but I want
and I would say that our relation I
should Express that our relationship
with the majority of the boards is very
good but it requires a willingness from
the regulatory bodies who may not
necessarily be on board with the
legislative changes to take affirmative
steps to modify their rules and I and
that's that's
challenging okay I understand um one
thing I'd like to ask everybody and it's
not aimed at any particular is if points
have been made before if possible please
don't repeat them so we can actually get
through the day um representative G my
question is thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question my question
is specific to these two boards have the
rules been completed and the change has
been
made no in fact they just propose
Engineers just propos rules that
contains additional subjective
requirements that we won't be able to
administer and we're currently
discussing in the office whether to
formally object during the jail car
process followup
followup so um so all the more reason it
sounds to me like it's not a good time
to for shove another change through if
there's um mitigating circumstances to
the changes being implemented from last
year
I can't comment on that but thank you
right thank you for for being careful
about that
I what I like I think there's a I'm
sensing a consensus and I would like to
just take a vote um you know if anybody
feels that there absolutely has to be
more said uh go ahead but i' really
prefer
yep how how much subject matter
expertise you have 57 boards how much
subject matter expertise field expertise
does oplc has to make this transition
and where I can see the subject matter
uh review for applicants would be a big
uh part of
some yes so we cannot we cannot evaluate
complaints that have subjective
components um no application should have
you know no application processes should
have subjective components but we're not
going to take that on um with objective
components there we can evaluate those
complaints and we have been for many
years or not complaints um license
applications in very
complicated um licensing Fields it's
just a matter of what the rules State
and that's where the subject matter
expertise comes into
play okay um unless somebody really has
something else they need to say we have
a motion of inexp to
legislate and I'd like to take a vote on
it
okay um all in
favor or maybe the easiest thing is I'll
go through representative
Brown um I'm GNA vote Yes hesitantly
with the hope that this becomes more
efficient and better for the people
coming to New Hampshire to get licenses
um representative
Bailey yes my primary concern would be
the size of the
board um okay um representative
maputi I think giving a pause I would
support and making the process simple
yes and representative G yes and the
chair will vote Yes on this one as well
so 5 to zero we're going to recommend uh
itl to the full committee all right I'm
going to close
the uh subcommittee work session on
House Bill
1286 I'm going to open the uh
subcommittee work session on
1285 um one thing I'd like to say is
that and this is to everybody not a
particular thing but if there are
questions let's say to oplc or anybody
else which are not directly pertinent
the bill and necessary for the person to
make a decision I would suggest asking
them after the hearing um and you know
director Courtney's been very responsive
uh to that sort of thing and I'm sure
other people could answer questions as
well
so with that
said this is relative to merging the
board of Podiatry into the Board of
Medicine there's some similarities to
the um you know prior thing Al some some
complications so any thoughts on
this yeah represent Brown thank you Mr
chair so I guess let's start in the same
place with asking
oplc as we stand now with the rule with
the what has been passed
statutorily the the uh for both of these
boards has their scope of work decreased
they're they're just like we said
they're not handling applications so
each of these boards now has less to do
than they may have had if once the dust
settles yes correct actually we've
already onboarded medicine and Podiatry
into the new process and they are not
reviewing complaints unless there's a
issue of concern such as um a criminal
history records check that requires
review thank you okay maybe you've
already answered it but is the ru making
process that any that's required to deal
with last year's
legislation uh going well done or
whatever for uh for these boards the
oplc ru making is completed the board
rule making is not completed okay do the
the rules for the either of these boards
have
problems being in significant conflict
with um the statutes that have changed
no I would say that I mean there are
references to the board reviewing
applications we've just taken the
position that those rules are superseded
by our statute and there the pediatry
both pediatry and Medicine their rules
do not contain subjective components we
have been evaluating those licensing
applications for years so it the
transition has has gone smoothly okay
thank you uh representative mja py thank
you Mr
chair how is the board functioning as of
now in terms of with regard to oplc
timeliness Quorum some of the issues
that oplc brought about other boards in
this particular
board um are there big concerns in terms
of me meeting and the Quorum
requirement so so medicine meets much
more frequently than patry Podiatry at
most meets um quarterly medicine meets
at least monthly and and they have a lot
more on their agenda they have a lot
more complaints um than Podiatry and I
would say are extremely engaged um
Podiatry it looks like
met four times last year they had three
cancelled
meetings follow up thank you Mr chair um
so is p you know
podiatrist uh concerned because medicine
is such an intense and so many fields
will that
overshadow the request for the
podiatrist uh need or how will they
Bubble Up in the priority of the board
so patris is a small field there's about
100 lenses um which I think was part of
the basis for the request I can't speak
for the governor's office so certainly
the uh podiatrist member On The Board of
Medicine would would devote more time um
you know we heard some concerns
regarding Physicians you know and and
their handling of uh cases that falls
under the podiatrist uh scope of
practice so there could be a benefit
there um but certainly to that member
that would represent more time
involved okay um anyone
else okay is there anybody um else here
just to for for who Wants to speak on
this
bill okay
uh if you could come
up and uh I don't remember if you were
here um last time but uh we heard a lot
of testimony on how wonderful
podiatrists are and the difference
between what they do and Physicians and
all of that and I do not think that's
going to be pertinent to what we're
doing today so i' rather not deal with
that but okay um my name is Dr David
Conway I I did submit written testimony
um I don't have a whole lot to add to
that and I really came today to see if
you had any specific questions that were
not answered in my testimony okay
anyone you have something representative
so if I'm translating this correctly any
of these boards get
merged uh you as a member of the board
are going to go to that board and you're
going to hear topic that aren't
associated with your
field if if you're merging pediatrist
with something else you're going to be
sitting in the board listening to issues
about a different field than what you're
in I guess the overall question is does
that still make our process more
efficient and better for people coming
in from the
outside to to get work here or or is it
as some have said make it a problem for
people to go to the board because they
have to spend more time listening to
items they wouldn't normally listen to
and that's a long
question okay first off I'm no longer a
member of the board yeah I'm here as a
public member having served on the board
having served on the medical review
subcommittee um
and most recently I was uh The Physician
investigator for the board up until July
1st when the position was eliminated
along with the medical review
subcommittee um and
my experience both in that position as
well as on the board is that there's a
huge backlog of cases of
complaints that when I was the
investigator there were when I first
took the job there were complaints that
went back to 2019 that had never been
seen by a
physician With The Changes here um I
think that just has the potential to uh
increase that backlog and to make it
less efficient for the board to review
complaints it's not an issue of uh gee
we need to do something to make
licensing easier uh right now the
board participates in compact licensing
which is licensing Physicians from out
of state who have no um who have valid
licenses in other states with nothing
that would be of a concern uh to the
board so it's fair uh director Courtney
could address that if you needed other
questions
um just a moment I I want to follow up a
little bit on this and then um so look
at your your what you sent us um it
seems like a major part of the complaint
is the impact of the reduction of the
number of board members um I mean if we
decided to move forward with the merger
um we could address that separately and
and make changes there so you know if
the board size were not
reduced um or I'd have to think about
about maybe even uh you know increased a
little bit to add somebody people from
Podiatry would that alleviate a lot of
your concerns or what would be the
concerns in addition to that if that
of another concern was the difficulty in
finding outside investigators who did
not have expertise in a specific
specialty to review cases um that was a
real challenge for me as the
investigator I know it was a challenge
for other investigators as well um so
that if you ask me would you please
review this case on uh uh for a um
neonatologist somebody who takes care of
of sick premature kids I would be very
uncomfortable reviewing that I would
reach out to somebody with more
expertise okay um director Courtney
could you address and what I'm looking
for particular is with all the changes
how was any of this changed in
situation thank you so my position is
that the backlog in large part was
created by the fact that the MRC um was
not meeting and was and when they were
meeting um we're committing to only
reviewing one case per person at a time
when you receive about 400 complaints a
year clearly the math doesn't add up so
um I think that with the new process we
are making our way and significant
Headway through the backlog by
leveraging um consultant work paid
consultant work with experts in their
field to assist with that process it's
always going to be the case that
particularly in healthcare that cases
require expertise that may not
necessarily be expertise that a member
of the board has um that's just because
of the varied Specialties in medicine
and so we have to go outside and instead
of asking for favors and asking for PE
you know begging people to review cases
um the better approach is to pay them
for their work and to get uh true
experts to opine in a timely fashion and
move those cases forward so that's the
way we're currently handling it I think
that's how we would handle it with you
know if if they were merged I mean we're
going to continue to handle it in that
in that way okay that's been working
well you've been able to find um um you
know people to to do that work yeah
we've had a couple of strange cases
lately um involving specific Specialties
and um we've been able to find experts
and contract for those Services okay
thank
you repr brown we're not trying to get
into a debate here no no no a quick
followup Mr chair with you so I i' I've
said several times that it's important
to increase efficiency and help people
to get licenses but if you would would
repeat what you stated last week that
that really isn't the goal of Licensing
well I
mean I mean the goal of LIC the only
legitimate purpose for licensing at all
is to protect public health and safety
okay
now in doing that if we believe
licensing is the solution then I think
you know we have a a duty to try and
have it be as least burdensome as
possible on the people being licensed to
redu to you know have have more people
who are available to meet uh you know
the consumer's needs and and you know to
to keep the cost down uh for the people
working in the field because that's
going to help with the whole efficiency
and meeting needs thank you okay uh I
know represent M py has question yeah um
totally how many fields medical Fields
approximately I'm not asking for exact
board that's a question I really can't
answer I no no problem uh follow with
that Mr chair certainly uh so this is to
uh director
Courtney um the
specialty
uh in the field is uh expert field I
mean specialty field expert being called
or cons uh consultant paid consultant
coming has it been a new practice or has
it been something that you've used
before oplc has used
before I think I think previously the
boards and oplc had used it
intermittently but they had more
commonly relied on Experts um on the
board I I think that's problematic for
multiple reasons um you know in a legal
case I mean it's not just specific to
administrative law you need to find an
expert in that particular field and and
you need to go out and find that person
to testify to support your case and so
that's what we're doing now much like in
criminal cases or civil cases requiring
specialized knowledge training and
experience and it's working well because
the boards are able to be the
adjudicating body and the experts are
able to provide that opinion upon which
can rely or choose to Discount um so
your question about how I mean any
specialty so in physician licensing we
only license The Physician they're not
required to be board certified so it's
any any specialist who is a physician is
licensed under the Board of
Medicine um all right if you have
something brief oh no oh
well just I I realized the mic the mic
if if you're going to speak sorry I
realize you've asked us not to debate I
just want to
that in my time on the board and as
physici investigator nobody was being
paid as an outside investigator I I
understand and it's not any criticism of
how things were done before or any
particular person so that's not all
right
so is this conversation going exactly
the same direction as our last
conversation yes uh it's leaning that
way um I I have one more thing I guess
um right now the Board of Medicine is
handing a wide R handling a wide range
of
Specialties and again you may not be
able to answer this and I don't think
there's and and sah you can uh take a
seat if you would take a seat sure okay
thank you I don't see anybody here to
represent the podiatrist otherwise I
wouldn't ask you this but I guess the
question is is there anything special
about
Podiatry that would make it different
than just just another medical specialty
where that might make it problematic
Medicine I don't know that I can answer
it I would say probably I don't think so
I mean I've always viewed it as you know
a type of medicine you know podiatric
medicine but I know the P podiatrists
feel differently um actually follow up
to that our pediatrist MDS with a
specialty or something different they
have a different um what is it D what is
it I should know well it's a different
they have a different
doctorate okay education is different
criteria I know that there's in the
doctor end you've got MDS and ODS and
and NDS yes and they all kind of go
through similar but different things is
Podiatry within that range of difference
or something more much more different I
guess is so that's my understanding I
know that they disagree but that's my
understanding our board currently our
Board of Medicine currently regulates
dos and MDS Y and other states have
actually separated the two but we
regulate both and so this is proposing
to bring in the additional um all right
um let Bailey go first he hasn't asked
anything and then I do recall them
feeling well I don't know what they felt
but they they pointed out that doctors
often don't ask people to take their
socks
off they were the only ones that
actually looked at feet or the color of
feet or they were just distinguishing
themselves that unless you had a
specific foot complaint the doctor
wouldn't necessarily pay that much
attention to your feet whereas they did
I I heard that and I'm I'm sure that's
true to some extent um my primary care
doctor actually does look at my feet
um uh any any general visit um but
there's I mean there's s significant
differences between different Medical
Specialties as well I mean the
radiologist isn't going to look at your
feet unless you're getting X-ray your
feet Grant but okay um represent MTI
yeah uh couple of questions in terms of
um in other states neighboring how is
this going to impact our compact in
terms of if Podiatry and medicine is
separate in other states
and will that affect our
compact
participation no correct the record DPM
is their um degree uh it won't impact
compacts I mean the medicine compact is
strictly for certain Physicians I
actually don't like the compact I find
that our process that we adopted here
last year is much more efficient um it
currently takes about six weeks to get
somebody licensed under the compact but
putting that aside it's not going to
impact our state participation in the
compact there was two questions the
second one was are sorry the podiatrist
is it separate board and separate
yes uh representative Brown and then
representative G sorry he got in there
was she first I I think you were but go
on I'm not too worried about it okay uh
thank you Mr chair uh director Courtney
how many you probably don't know this uh
it appears that we have a separate board
for kind of a separate degree does that
happen often and that's a really broad
question but it seems like they could be
all lumped in medical and if the
gentleman back there disagrees I'd love
to hear that but compared to some of our
other boards so I'm sure Dr cway has an
opinion on this and I would be really
interested in hearing it and because my
understanding is there has been
culturally there has not always been
acceptance of other types of degrees
like Chiropractic uh naturopathic um
even podiatric medicine and I think that
may have contributed to why they haven't
been regulated under one board
historically um but obviously there are
differences and so yeah follow up follow
up just because you could break
Engineers out into to separate boards if
you wanted to because some of those
disciplines are quite different from
each other this to it so any follow up
on that is there is the is having dos
and NDS together in the Board of
Medicine with MDS is that cause serious
problems has that worked
okay dos and MDS no that's been fine
with and NDS as well ND are regulated
separately they separ that's right thank
you that probably would be
problematic um representative
G Mi Mr chair I'd like I'm prepared to
to make a motion if you're ready to
accept one
um I I'm okay with that Y and that's so
uh we need a second and what's the
motion first of all I move we itl this
bill okay and somebody want a second it
so okay so representative G speak to
your
motion for many of the same reasons as
my previous motion on the previous bill
I think that we've made a lot of changes
that the board is continuing to work
through the process with opl I think
that we have an oversight committee
that's looking at how that process is
moving and rather than overwhelm the
difference in my opinion we discussed a
difference between Podiatry and whether
it could be in or should be in the fact
of the matter is it has not been in it
has been a separate board and we've made
a lot of changes and let's give people a
year at least to work with the oversight
committee continue to work with oplc and
next year we could look at this matter
again representa monu you want to speak
to your second yeah um we were not able
to address I uh 100% agree with the
representative G and also we did not
address the fact that number of
members shrinking the board increases
the
responsibility that especially this is
Medical Board and this affects the
public safety even more and we got to be
very careful in how we do that how we
Implement that so with that I think
giving another year to see how it all
works out would be uh very helpful thank
you okay um okay so on that point just a
procedural thing if we were let's say to
defeat the itl if that were to happen
that then we could proceed to uh
recommend an amendment and uh which you
know I I'll give my position so I think
that Podiatry is another form of a
doctor you know some type of doctor I
know the training is different um so I'm
going to vote against the itl although
not my view isn't super strong on that
um but if the itl were to be uh defeated
we could then moved to make an amendment
which I would suggest to change the uh
you know the current membership of the
board in that's in the bill so I that's
a good point and the same I you know
part of the reason I'm
not it isn't a strong position is that I
think there might be some benefit to
doing it it's it's probably not huge and
there is still the I think there's less
of an issue maybe in these boards um
having them settle down from the changes
we made last year because it sounds like
there that's working pretty well there's
more of an issue on the boards on the
previous Bill and so while I saw and you
know so but any other discussion before
we take a vote represent of gold well I
just would say we did not hear from the
podiatrist at this hearing so um I would
have been glad to have had them but
they're not here I know I know okay I
but I have all opposition for this one
well I I will say to that because that's
been that Point's been made before
um well certainly that's something to
look
at you know if the legislature this is
the the regulation be done under the
authority of the
legislature and you know it's our duty
to do what we think is best for the
people to
State and you know there may be you know
especially before there was licensing
there may have been people who are
practicing in the field who might have
opposed licensing but that doesn't mean
that the legislature shouldn't have done
what they did so you you know while
that's of Interest I don't it should not
be determinative no I I agree I'm just
taking it down a totality sure um
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair I I think you make a good point I
think I'm kind of in the same mindset
that you are I wouldn't oppose itl if we
all agreed to follow that through on the
day we exact the bill however if it
doesn't pass I think we should talk now
membership I agree we should have a we
we shouldn't that we should have an
amendment that has an acceptable we have
this motion on the floor um if
it if the it passes and that's our
recommendation of the committee there's
nothing to keep someone from bringing an
amendment to the full
committee um and you know argue against
itl before the full committee and offer
the amendment
it have less of a chance than if the
subcommittee did but but uh I don't
think we can get into discussing that
while we've got an itail motion on the
table so representative G I'll just sum
up with uh my husband has observed much
of the proceedings of this body and he
has decided that our state motto should
go from Live Free or Die to now is not
the time and I would say on this bill
for this year now is not the time my
condolences to your husband been
watching all this but uh any anyone else
on the itl motion I think we've all
pretty much said okay um so
representative Brown yes yes on the it
representative
Bailey yes okay yes okay uh
maputi yes representative Gould yes and
the chair is going to vote no but he's
not terribly upset so okay I'm going to
close the um the sub commmittee work
session on House Bill
1285 and get organized and then
uh uh briefly if you'd like very because
we are we got a big Bill ahead of us but
okay I didn't comment it comment on it
in my written uh testimony but there is
a bill House Bill 322 specifically
looking to study the Board of Medicine
um and the Board of Medicine has gone
through several audits in the past the
most recent one is 2000 is uh 2008 I
don't recall the dates on the other ones
butor was house 3:22 322 yes sir okay um
so that is something to keep in mind
that all right actually that would have
been good to know because that would
have been another reason to to wait
until that assuming that bill passes we
don't know
no um it's interesting we haven't that
must have gone to HHS I suppose
establishing a committee to study in
committee or commer probably I would
anyway we we can yeah okay all right
thank you um I'm going to open the
subcommittee work session on House Bill
1271 um I looked I just want to give you
my thoughts on how to proceed and see if
people
agree um this is most of this is
converting boards from
um the you know to an Advisory Board
there's one case where it's merging
boards um massage therapists and
reflexology and um some other things and
you know if we were to you know retain
even any of this bill we're going to
have to get rid of um the section that
eliminates the board of registry of
medical technicians since we already did
that at least we recommended it in uh
1410 I think it was um and so I think
we'd like to do is
maybe uh talk a little bit and have some
input from oplc although uh Mr ous did
send
in he had emailed initially to some of
us and then it was shared with the full
committee
um you know their take on actually I
printed copies so I'll hand them out
thank you um one
two
three can hand those on on
uh opl C's take on advisory boards and
um so I'd like to talk about advisory
boards in general first and then I'd
suggest that we go through these one at
a time these eight of them and um to see
which ones you know we may make
different decisions on different ones
and the first one will be acupuncture I
think we have a couple people from the
AC acupuncture Community here to talk on
those specifically but
um so people can look at that and if you
have any questions for anyone from oplc
related to the general topic of advisory
them and actually uh Mr oo if you could
come up and just kind of summarize them
questions because I'm not sure people uh
I don't remember when this got emailed
to the full board and so I'm not sure if
people had a chance to look at
it I think it went out Wednesday to the
full board okay Douglas ster how oplc
general counsel so I put in my email
that this was not really something I
ever intended to share it was just kind
of conversations I was having with board
members or members of the public and
just kind of jotting down notes for my
own benefit um but it sort of goes
through if I was going to have a
conversation and explain to somebody
what an Advisory Board was sort of the
office's role uh just how I envisioned
an Advisory Board working within the
office and I I hopefully that I mean
it's bullet points just talking points
they kind of speak for themselves um but
it just touches on like the first bullet
there's a lot of questions around
subject matter experts and and how it is
our responsibility as Protectors of the
public to always rely on subject matter
experts Advisory board non-advisory
board uh the Sherman Act coverage which
I think we have talked about quite a bit
in hearings but just that sort of
liability on the individual on the state
if those Market participants and there
is an adequate State oversight
um one of the concerns again it has to
do with the subject matter experts is
does this put too much power in the
hands of the executive director can the
executive director go and promulgate
rules without any board input and I I
genuinely don't think that's the case
because I think in statute we are
required to work with the boards to
promulgate rules to come up with the
right rules and there's also
opportunities built in the system in 541
there's public hearings there's
opportunity to comment and if the boards
feel they aren't being heard 100%
they're going to show up at the Jael car
and say so I've seen it happen so uh not
with this agency by the
[Laughter]
way um and then non-advisory to advisory
it's the same kind of thing if you have
a well functioning Advisory Board really
from the board's perspective you
shouldn't see a lot of difference as far
as you're still going to show up you're
still going to be help drafting rules
you're going to promulgate rules a lot
of the benefits come though when there's
changes that are proposed at the Jael
car or they're kind of effective and
efficiency changes it's more of a lean
process bill in my opinion than than
anything else is we don't have to wait
another month to send a proposal to to
the board and have them vote on it we
can contact board members we can have
the conversations and maybe we can move
things along
and then the other one
is again from our perspective advisory
non-advisory is not in any way a
reflection
on the profession itself a lot of these
are legal concerns are efficiency
concerns to me it's it's protecting the
state it's helping in some cases uh move
things along just a little bit faster
and so that's kind of what I I
summarized in here um
just these are the talking points if I
was going to try and put somebody's mind
at ease about advisory versus
non-advisory one clarifica clarification
is uh when you're talking about
liability you mention the state you also
mention individuals are those the
individuals serving on the board correct
okay so they're open if there were an
antitrust lawsuit are they open to
individual
liability potentially I I mean it's it's
a stronger argument for personal
liability without The Advisory Board
place especially in these boards where
there's only a handful of people uh in
the profession or individuals
participating okay any questions for uh
Brown and then Mt py uh thank you Mr
chair I you have to clarify that for me
so B all of our boards
now how are they covered
Summer from as state actors they'd be
covering under 99d okay so essentially
if you're acting in good faith on behalf
of the state the Attorney General's
office is going to come in they'll
defend you and more than likely there
won't be personal liability and I'm
speaking in kind of these I'm doing that
attorney thing where it's always a maybe
right because I never know what it
what's going to happen or the
particulars of a case but there's much
better Protections in place if you're
acting with that state coverage than
than when it's not there a followup
followup so
and so that wouldn't be the case in The
Advisory board or am I totally lost
do you want to do
sorry uh what the what the advisory does
is give uh more State oversight and so
that just creates a better argument for
why there should not be personal
liability should something happen should
uh the board be sued and ju and just to
follow up to that I know on the South
Carolina case has been talked about was
there actual individual liability found
for the board members that I don't know
but the issue is really this if the
state if the actor is not a member of
the profession then it undercuts the
argument that there's any antitrust
issues going on because I'm a lawyer
what do I care if the podiatrists have
you know if we're limiting competition
so that's really the theory there in the
Anti-Trust world is that the final actor
is not a member of the
profession yeah as I understand it the
issue is you have people who are in the
profession determining who can be in the
profession and how they get uh dealt
with if they're accused of something and
that's kind of
problematic yeah follow I'm sorry I'm
really sorry everybody in the
room
so so for that question is there a
difference between an Advisory Board and
a board or a board are all of so our
boards aren't advisory boards or I'm
going totally backwards now we we have
seven right now that are advisory and
one of them before you right now is
massage and
reflexology and I have spoken with the
massage board Advisory Board and they
would like to be
merged they think that reflexology Asian
Bodywork and structural integration
should be part of massage it used to be
part of massage I guess there was a
separation conflict in the profession
years ago but they think they should be
back together okay we can get into the
details on that when we get down to that
one any uh so muchy thank you madam Mr
chair I'm seeing uh representative
Maguire
there um
so advisory versus
um non licensing uh board legal versus
fiary responsibility of individual board
can you just tell me a little more about
the difference or is there no
difference
so really the issue is this when we talk
about ant when we talk about Market
participants making decisions that
impact competition in the field the
argument is that and this is what the
Supreme Court recognized that although
they although we because I I have I have
multiple hats too um can wear multiple
hats you can't truly ever take off your
professional hat and that there is an
argument to be made um there are
concerns regarding antitrust and so with
respect to liability and Immunity if you
make a decision recklessly in this case
if you make a decision to regulate
imposed requirements to limit
competition and you should have known
that that was going to happen then
technically under 99d you may not be
subject you may not be subject or
entitled to
indemnification um and defense so that's
the issue but if at the end of the day
on an Advisory Board model they make a
recommendation to a body that is not a
member of the profession that really
provides them with coverage because they
didn't make the
decision maybe I can just a moment I
think there might be I mean and correct
me if I'm wrong in in stating this so
with a regular
board uh as far as rulle making on
things like you how you get a license or
or or other things the board actually
does the ru making uh hopefully in with
help or staff help or whatever from oplc
but they're responsible for doing the ru
making and if there's a a complaint they
actually make the decision on how the
complaint's going to be handled but an
Advisory Board the ru making is actually
done by oplc in consultation with the
board but the ultimate responsibility
for those rules is
oplc and similarly for um adjudicated
complaints um either it's obvious an
oplc can can deal with it or if there's
some you need subject matter information
either you can get it outside or you
could consult with the board but
ultimately that decision and the
adjudication is the responsibility of
oplc and that's how you get away from
people who are Market you know they're
they're working in the field from being
put in a position of making decisions
that directly affect their peers which
could be a problem is that good that's
absolutely correct and I I think my body
art microblading example uh that I
previously testified to you is a great
example of that because had that board
not been advisory they would not have
moved forward with the rul making based
on the pressures they were getting in
the industry um and but they had a
sagittary obligation to do so and those
those reasons were purely based on
limiting competition um so that's a
prime example so I mean the point is
there have been although I don't as far
as I know we haven't been sued on it um
you can correct me but there have been
situations where if we were it could
have been you know dicey if nothing else
yes we weren't suited on the body art
because I said too bad so sad we need to
move forward with rul making and we now
have rules because they're Advisory
board so I was able to step in and make
those rules okay thank you um represent
M py and Brown
so you know I'm trying to follow the um
path here so last year legislation did a
lot of changes to take the rule making
or licensing from the regulatory board
to give it to
oplc and they are rule making for the
profession but not licensing that would
uh help with with the profession growth
or new licenses the competition if I
correctly say you're blind to you know
when the a new applicant submits an
application because it's not a
professional U it's not a you know so
the oplc is blind in that sense to say
what the applicant is just so I see
that um did that change change the
regulatory board's function in terms of
making that more an advisory role versus
regulatory board because that function
was removed from the legislation do you
know what I'm trying to get out I think
a lot of the changes gave the process
piece to the oplc but as far as like
licensing criteria that would remain
with the board and the oplc wouldn't
have the authority to force them to rule
that yeah so in that
case
is is it a good balance at this point
when the shift is happening to leave it
at R regulatory board and automatically
when that things changes it becomes an
advisory mostly an advisory role because
it's not completely transition that's a
challenging question I think because
you'd have to look at each board in
right there's different circumstances
for different boards some boards I mean
we had a conversation just a few minutes
ago Board of Medicine you know their
transition to us processing the
applications has gone very smoothly
where it's been more challenging for
other boards
so so it's it's sort of a challenging
answer but but again I also want to
point out that a lot of this is for the
protection of the State and for the
protection of the individual serving on
the board and again if it is a well
functioning board regardless of whether
they have the authority we have the
authority we're going to try and have
that collaborative experience and and
draft good
rules I would hang on I would agree with
that I would also say that it it
certainly limits the risk but to Doug's
point you need to look at the actual
board to understand the the significance
of the risk um Midwifery for example
that has on average 30 members uh or
lienes and they all know each other I
would say that's a pretty high risk
which one was that Midwifery okay you
know other boards if and this is not
contemplated but if you had 10,000
lenses um and the licenses didn't own
businesses but worked in different
facilities that's probably low risk so I
think those are the things that you need
to to look at and what I'd like to add
something that and again correct me if
I'm wrong um
if if it's a a a regulatory board rather
than
advisory they uh make the rules or they
could choose not to make the rules and I
think as the example she gave there have
been cases where boards maybe didn't
entirely agree with what the legislature
did in statute and declined to create
rules at all and that puts oplc in a a
position where they are statuto supposed
to do things but they don't have the
rules to do it but you know
hopefully you know the the boards and
oplc work well together and a lot of you
know some most case I think I hope it
works but in the cases where a board
chooses not to if their advisory as she
had mentioned in the one case that
actually happened um oplc can move
forward and actually get the rules
created that the legislature wanted them
to do if that is that good summary yes
that's accurate okay thank you so much
py yeah so so sorry well quick quick
followup and then representative Brown
so where does the jel car come into this
uh advisory Regulatory and force not
forcing I don't want to use the word
forcing uh facilitate or enhance opl C's
ability or the legislative mandate to be
implemented does jel car play a
role no so I mean the legislature will
say you have an obligation to Draft
rules and unless you bring rules forward
to jail car there's no review so so
that's the challenge representative
Brown um thank you Mr chair except that
your rules would expire and you would
have none potentially 10 years if you're
if you're up against expiration then you
have to renew if you don't then you have
none certainly unless your goal is to
not have any rules and not implement the
statutory objective right right um
so
uh why would not in this case every
board be an Advisory board if we want to
provide indemnification for our
volunteers I just I think we recognize
that's not practical um in New Hampshire
we have a long history of a regulatory
framework that has independent
regulatory bodies we have fully
functioning larger boards that meet
regularly and I think we can minimize
that risk through training um and
providing staff support but when you
have a board that doesn't meet regularly
because there's not a lot to do it
increases the risk because they're not
trained you have to continue to train
them um and provide that staff support
and then when you have a board that you
know is five members of let's say a 100
person ly population that also increases
the risk I just don't think it's
practical thank you okay um anyone else
on this uh and this right now I just
want to do this first part to make sure
people have a real understanding ing of
advisory versus regulatory boards and
what the issues are so anything else
specific to that my just question to or
maybe the chair
or is this
sweeping change of everything listing
conversion is one siiz fitall kind of
approach that might be a little
more I mean my difficult my view is that
I mean I would support making every
board Advisory board but there are
people that that have a different
view um but I think and you can answer I
think these are some of the boards where
there might be more issues maybe because
there aren't a large number of uh people
licensed or for other
reasons is that yes I think
representative McGuire testified that it
was fewer than 500 lenes or 200 with the
exception of Massage Therapy but it's
already a massage or it's already an
Advisory Board okay yeah so that there's
so it's not just a sweeping everything
there's 57 I think if I remember
correctly board seven are advised
already this is
addressing really eight because we got
rid of one um and so and these are the
ones where the these concerns about a
regulat board are are the biggest so
it's it's not sweeping everything it's
ones that have some similar
characteristics um maybe this uh can uh
either
uh
oplc can answer off these nine or 10
boards that are or eight how many
voluntarily wants to shift from advisory
to I mean regular atory to advisory or
advisory to regulatory do you have any
idea so I know nursing home
administrators is interested because
they've had some tough cases lately and
they don't like opining or making
decisions that impact their peer Group
which makes sense because it's such a
small field um and massage hasn't
questioned whether they should be
advisory they are advisory and they are
interested in emerging with
reflexology
follow up so the out of eight three are
on their own want to be an advisory well
I haven't had Direct conversations with
G I mean they've only
met couple of times in the last year
Family mediators just had two meetings
but prior to that had not been meeting
um and that that board there are some
significant challenges because there are
about um 50 lenes there and I which one
is that a family mediators okay I know
Midwifery Council had previously agreed
to different language not contained in
this bill um I know that they don't like
the concept but they did agree to
language that that would move them to an
advisory model and I'd be happy to
provide you with that um I think
somebody did show up from the
acupuncturist board in opposition
correct um we had a robust public
hearing yeah I I would say
that well it would be it's great if the
board supports it I wouldn't say that
should weigh heavily because there
are I mean that even asking the board in
one sense puts them in difficult
position so the question is you have
people who work in the field regulatory
regulating their
peers and if you ask them and they say
now we want to stay a regulatory board
you're kind of no I'm not asking for
asking them but I said if on their own
they have said you know it would be a
much better functioning for our
profession there is an inclination to
cooperate rather than forcing something
and it's all a volunteer one so instead
of getting that you know if there is a
Buy in already and they're coming up
with
that I I understand that my only thing
I'd say is there have been cases and
there's a particular case that I think
we dealt with prior to this year um
where the board was not creating the
rules that statute told them to and in
that case CH moving them to advisory is
not something I would be asking them so
that's all and I'm and I hope this is
rare and most of the boards are are
working well with LC uh representative
I'm not I've really cut your pay now
because I don't think she's going to let
you serve here and and still work
there uh this just just kind of
anecdotal but it's it's it's also
tangentially uh related but I've also
had members of the public um both with
boards that have gone advisory in the
past and I don't want to specify which
one but one of the ones on this list
where members of the public have come
forward and said they appreciated the
board goinging advisory because the
board had not been responsive to the
members of the public whereas the LLC
was was able to do that so I also just
want to put that on the table uh even if
the board may not be we have heard cases
where where the public appreciates
it um well let me get somebody else U
representative Brown um I have two
questions Mr chair maybe you could
clarify what director Courtney said or
she she can um the decision to go to
advisory was less than 500 lenses or was
I not hearing maybe it was 300 I don't
remember 200 yes it was 200
representative uh corrected me
thankfully it was 200 thank you so and
follow up second question yeah looking
at page 44 and
45 my quick count which could be not
quite accurate but I'm showing there
will be 11 advisory boards and
approximately 44 other boards does that
sound about right that sounds right
okay um if there 14
advisory well you'd be merging massage
and
reflexology okay we're about about the
same yeah
okay I would like to move on from this I
mean it's uh it's about 20 of noon would
you like a motion Mr chair uh no I'm not
looking for a motion just a moment we're
going to get to acupuncturist in a
minute um this
wasn't I mean unless somebody wants to
make an itl on the whole bill which I
would not like to get um but um this was
just these all you know all but a couple
of these deal with moving from a
statutory to an Advisory board so I
thought it would be useful
to have that discussion up front instead
of for each one of them so I'm not
looking for motion oh uh my motion would
be OTP but if you're not ready for that
actually I'll be glad to take OTP sure I
move I move OTP on House
Bill 1271 hang on uh you have a point
actually we actually have to have an
amendment I was just gonna say was
number nine okay I I would um if you
want to go that route you need to
uh it needs to be with an amendment that
eliminates the section in here dealing
with the board of registration medical
technicians because in House Bill 1410
we already got rid of them but but you
can make that motion we don't we don't
have to have the amendment drafted today
I mean if if you
know make a motion with an amendment
actually why don't you make a motion
with an amendment to that effect first
because we're going to need it anyway
and then we'll move to otpa if that's
what you want to okay I move that we
1271 to eliminate the section you just
mentioned okay that's uh section 83 of
the bill registration medical Tech right
it's page 39 line 7 through 44 line 11
or 7 to 11 and uh which is it's a
multiple sections in there but but
that's okay great um uh I'll second it
that was hanging a moment that school
excuse me Mr chair yep would that also
89 right there's uh the the list would
also have to be amended the definition
of board that's that's all of the
medical I think that's all of the
medical technicians isn't it I was just
um well
actually there is a yeah there's
a so line 89 Page 44 11 on 44 certainly
line
10 right I think I think I said through
Page um
40 through Page 44 line 11 through that
so that is included
yes um someone seconding this I actually
I said I would yeah I can't support it
sorry well now this
amendment if we do anything other but a
final
itl this is sort of like we have to
because we we past 1410 yeah and so
it'll take it out of here now if let's
say the full
house uh does itl is
1410 then that's fine U because medical
technicians won't be taken out by that
bill and if we do pass some version of
this they won't be taken out by this if
we adopt the amendment so I I don't see
what your concern is about adopting this
amendment that's not just medical
technician with this one it's also uh
God gosh where is that one line I'm
trying to look at um if it concludes
something more than medical technicians
then did oh gosh page and line yeah I
that's what I'm looking
[Music]
at oh
shoot the Imaging P Imaging that is uh
hang on uh imaging
radiology page 44 line 25 I was only I
was only removing through line 11 on 44
no I understand we're talking about the
amendment oh do you want to no no I'm
not saying amend remove but we are just
doing peace meal of amendment there are
others that are in the bill so what line
page and line are you concerned
about page 44 we removed it in 14 what
line I need a line uh 25 but I have to
see corresponding we remove no in 1410
we removed the bill leaving it in
statute correct and this will change it
into advisory oh I see your point yeah
yeah so there is a conflict what we
removed in
1410 okay that is now is there that's
interest in the sections up front yep if
I may if you're talking about medical
imaging they're already advisory oh okay
so not an issue so that I mean it
doesn't need to be here well no this
this is this is um saying replace all of
that section the whole list with a new
list no I understand but it says repeat
if you see page 44 yep okay it's it's
all why is it double then it's already
in if it's an Advisory Board why it
should say online 13 12 and 13 of that
page it says that RSA is repealed and
reenacted Ed to read as follows so
instead of making individual line edits
they just replaced the whole thing and
so this includes the changes makes them
Advisory board but the boards that
already existed are still in here with
the same status as they were before and
since medical imagy and radiation
therapy now are advisory they're listed
here also as
advisory I mean that's just the way not
making it it it's maybe my brain is yeah
you can explain it better I think uh
representative that when you look in the
existing law the line are says the exact
same thing Advisory Board of Medical
Imaging and radiation
therapy so what they've done because
there's so many changes to this list we
wiped out the whole the whole list in
the RSA and just replace it with a new
list to make it easier I think overall
rather than repealing and reenacting all
the individual items does that make
sense I I get it but this is making a
sweeping change saying every board is an
Advisory board so no it's not first of
all there's a lot of here that are not
Advisory Board and and so the thing is
this amendment is just dealing with uh
the medical technicians now if we move
for and it's not saying you know if we
move forward and the committee were to
vote
otpa um or and the and the full you know
the house did and everything else then
it would it would make changes for you
know for the eight remaining actually
only seven would become advisory boards
because one already is but we're not
deciding that right now so because we we
could decide you know working in the
subcommittee further let's say we want
to keep we want to actually move some to
advisory boards and not others as part
of that you know add-on Amendment uh we
would need to make changes in this list
and that's fine so saying that we're
doing this this isn't like a final
Amendment this is like we did with 1410
we we agreed to pieces and then all the
pieces got merged together in one
amendment I like that approach where
1410 we did it bits and pieces then and
we're doing the same thing here in my
and not not making a motion to out of
pass at this point we did sections and
then we met again
that's may I yeah
so it's in the existing law that line
your mentioning is exactly the same
words so what this list has done
everything that we're suggesting to be
changed within the body of the law is
changed in that list everything we
haven't changed Remains the Same it was
just easier to make a whole new list
than doing individual line item changes
so voting in support of this amendment
does not commit
anyone to either otpa or to not making
other changes it's just I think this is
necessary because when this this goes
into effect it can't repeal that section
because the section will be gone or
there'll be conflicts between the two
bills but it's kind of you know it's a
it's not even housekeeping it's it's
just to it's not sweeping changes or
well this amendment does not in itself
say whether or not we're going to make
sweeping changes all it says is if we I
mean I would hope everybody would vote
for this amendment now that doesn't mean
you need to vote for otpa which would be
the next motion but if we do anything
with this bill other than itl which may
be what we do but then we should vote to
adopt that we to recommend this
amendment now if in the end the
committee votes it on the whole bill
we're not going to recommend an
amendment I mean this isn't some binding
thing okay more followup yes so the if I
may thank you Mr chair sorry to jump in
yeah so representative manag py so the
only changes that would would be
made are the ones that are before the
list so the specific sections are the
only boards that would be
changed this list is not a is not a
massive change so everything that has
been changed in here will end up in the
list things that haven't been changed in
here are the same in the list as they
are in the current law so the list is
not an overall massive change I I
understand uh representative uh Brown
thank you for clarifying some of it when
I'm looking through 46 pages of this
bill there are so many lines crossed off
and then my my what I'm planning on
doing with this I mean if we if we
decide otpa which I'm fine with but some
people may not then um then yeah we
won't look through all the rest of the
bill in detail if we don't do that then
my intent would be to go through Section
by section as we did with 1410 and talk
about whether it makes sense to do a
move to advisory for any one of them and
then if we decide to move individual
ones to advisory then we can look at the
language and say is there anything in
here that need that isn't okay and we
need to change I mean that's that's the
idea okay yeah right represent gou
procedural question certain so right now
we're talking about a specific amendment
to clean up the language in this bill to
match correct what we've all agreed on
recently as a subcommittee regarding the
medical
um
technicians then once we decide on that
Amendment we can have the
otpa um discussion if somebody makes the
motion we can have a discussion on that
that could include anybody bringing up
any concerns they have with the language
and or before the amendment either way
my request would be that we we ask
people to bring their um objections to
any part of the bill forward rather
than go through it piece by piece where
there's no objection the the only issue
and I'd be wonderfully happy with an
otpa out of the committee um the
only issue I have is if
we um if we do otpa if that motion if
that well can we take a vote on the
amendment first before we get to a
motion we don't have yet okay um all in
favor of amending to remove those lines
I mentioned about medical technician all
I all right I anyone
opposed no with just the technical right
okay so we're we've gotten that and then
I'm open to another
motion and so that's my procedural
question do should I make should we make
the motion and have the discussion where
people bring up any objections or do we
want to have the discussion and then
make the I would suggest um the problem
here's the deal and this is me trying to
be to not take advantage of the fact
that we're three to2 on this committee
so I I don't know I don't presume how
anybody's going to vote but um if we if
we you make the motion I'll be glad to
Second it we take a vote it ends up you
know I don't know could be 5 to nothing
but it's four to one or or 3 to2 or
whatever if the motion passes then we're
done okay which I'd be glad it's get
lunchtime but to be fair if you're
intent
is to then go over parts of the bill I
would suggest you not make the motion at
this time thank you Mr chair I would
like to hear what objections are I don't
want to review what we all agree on then
what then what I would s what I would
like to do and people can tell me if
they don't like it because there's
likely to be other than the the whole
thing on whether or not we want to make
anything advisory which I hope you know
we we talked about what I would like to
do is go through a board by board
they're in here now we may you know we
may not we may decide partway through we
don't need to go through the rest but um
so I would uh okay is that okay because
I don't know how we do it randomly
moving around but people have issues
with particular language that correct is
it is it at this procedurally uh is it
at subcommittee level that we say we
have interim study or um
but or is it at the board level here's
what would happen um we could go through
like we did on 1410 section by section
and we could take you know not a final
vote vote on what we want to do with
each
section um and then in the
end um once we've gone through it we
would need to take you know we somebody
can make a motion ought to pass with an
amendment that makes up all the the
change es that we voted on including the
one we just did and like 1410 and then
we would recommend that the commit the
subcommittee would recommend that and
then I'd go to OLS and get it drafted as
I did with the other one and then to the
full committee we would we would as a
subcommittee recommend that that
amendment that Consolidated all the
changes we wanted and then recommend
ought to pass with that Amendment if you
wanted we we can't I don't think interim
study parts of this it the whole bill is
going to either be otpa is now we have
an amend otpa um itl or interim study on
the whole bill uh but if there's things
in here which we don't think are ready
for prime time we could remove them from
the bill they wouldn't be separate
interim study but there's nothing that
says the committee can't study them or
people can't study them without an
interim
study that's clear yeah I um my for
clarification Mr chair um this is my
first time on this I mean this committee
uh so if you know I'm not looking at the
1410 how we did that that was a good
process same with
1676 where we did a lot of work and you
know you brought in a one you know
Amendment sure that full committee had
an opportunity to discuss and dialogue
and that's where I'm thinking our work
needs to be done at the subcommittee
level to do that work and bring it to
the full that's what I'm proposing okay
you know I'm proposing that we go
through the and we dealt with uh the
part nine a list on the front page in
the analysis because that one we had to
do that way I mean we don't have a
choice I don't think unless we want to
create two bills that are in
Conflict um and then and we had the
general discussion on advisory and what
I'd like like to do now if we're you
know unless everybody's agreed on otpa
um which I don't think they are I'd like
to move forward um because I mean you
know if we took an otpa motion here and
let's say it turn three to two and then
we'd be done and then we'd end up having
this this discussion the full committee
which is not useful no so okay all right
so can we proceed all right um I know
two people are here on acupuncture I'm
sorry I recognize uh the lady with the
badge um what do you what is your with
for so you work with the
boards okay and okay great thank you
sometimes she sits with them yeah I knew
I just wanted to make sure I
knew no that's fine that's fine um all
right
so I didn't turn my mic on for that
that's probably good uh no it's all
right mine's on you probably CR it um
okay so taking a quick look at um and if
people need a break why don't we take a
five minute break or so all right all
right we're going to recess for five
minutes or so five minute
okay a little longer yeah I'm just
looking I'll have to check my see how it
is why don't 10 10 minutes help check
here I'm fine well we'll take a a a
10minute we'll recess for 10 minutes
yeah because I again I'm in the
same thing I was last Friday I have to
work tonight so I gotta be out when do
you have to
leave 2:40 absolutely okay 2:30 would be
more comfortable all right so 2:30 we
by so yeah I think I'd like to at least
get through I have a parking meter
that's going to end at 10 of one why
don't I run out why don't you do that
now I mean I always Park in stor street
so we don't have that issue because it's
well
very much uh now we'll resume the
subcommittee work session on House Bill
1271 and I'd like to deal with um if you
look at the analysis uh the first part
which converts the board of acupuncture
licensing into an Advisory Board and
make other amendments implementing this
change and um that's on page one line
one through Page 6 line 10 of the
amendment of The Bill actually sorry of
the
bill page page one line one the
beginning through Page Six line
10 just one board
one board that's all it is just all the
acupuncture
stuff okay and um I know we have some
people uh here who'd like to speak on it
you're both welcome to come up and then
introduce yourselves and uh let us know
this is it when it's it's red when it's
on and you have to have it pretty close
to your mouth reasonably close
hi thank you for having me back again
I'm Elizabeth Rob and I'm a manchest I'm
an acupuncturist in
Manchester uh and I'm Tracy branstrom
I'm a PhD candidate at the University of
Chicago in the social sciences uh I do
research on the addiction crisis in New
England mainly in New Hampshire and
Vermont um and that's how I learned
about uh ACU detox or ER acupuncture
here and what was your last name
branstrom how spell it if you would b r
m okay thank you and I'm a certified ACU
detox Specialist or ads in New Hampshire
which is why I'm here okay thank
you so I just want to provide a few
comments hopefully it will help you if
you're not still not certain about where
to stand on this um the question that
was asked during the Committee hearing
was what would change if HB um 1271
becomes law so I have two points um
first is currently the acupuncture board
doesn't have any acupuncture
detoxification Specialists um they're a
lower tier of
certification and it's important that
they have representation and I can point
to an example that came up this week
since that hearing um the acupuncture
board approved rules that will go to the
Jael car next month pertaining to lure
by endorsement and the rules that the
acupuncture board approved for
pertaining to acupuncture detoxification
specialist conflict with the law and I
happened to see them as a fluke so I
contacted oplc myself and showed them
what the statutes are but if they had an
Acu detox specialist on the board
looking after those other people who are
certified as adss that might not have
happened um so that brings me to my
second point which is acupuncturists
know acupuncture but we don't know
regulation
um executive director Lindsay brought up
the Supreme Court case about the North
Carolina dentist versus the tooth
whiteners that's the is that the Sherman
Act oh okay um so after that precedent
was sent was set the North Carolina
acupuncture board lost a countersuit to
the physical therapy board for
anti-competitive behavior um I got my
first licensed a practice in North
Carolina and um in 2020 I guess I was
still on their email list so I got an
email asking if I personally wanted to
chip in to help them cover $60,000 in
legal expenses and that was reduced from
180,000 and just out of curiosity
earlier this week I went on an
acupuncture group on Facebook and I just
said hey does anyone know if the North
Carolina acupuncture board was able to
pay off their legal expenses from being
counter sued by the physical therapists
and one person spoke up and he said that
he was on the board at the time that it
was the 180,000 and that each individual
member of the board was personally sued
$5
million do would you like screenshots I
didn't think to bring
them okay okay
um
so so um this again we talked about how
this would protect the boards um but not
only that it would protect individual
practitioners like me I can approach I
would think that I could approach an
Advisory board that has stronger legal
counsel from oplc to talk about ways in
which I think our law and our
rules are
anti-competitive and then if changes
need if it's determined that changes
need to be made we can move forward
together because everyone and then
everyone because everyone's on the same
page and that would
save your committee a lot of referee
between us which has been happening for
some time now so does that make sense if
I could just ask a clarification on that
um so is it that you could more easily
approach an Advisory Board because the
regulat the regulatory board has more
direct control over you making a living
and if they have an issue with you you
might have concerns um I don't know if
that's is that's what I heard I don't
know if that's what you intended I meant
that if so with oplc had more direct
control over an Advisory Board guiding
them on how to create laws that are not
anti-competitive I would feel more
comfortable going and speaking directly
does that is it because you think it's
more likely they would actually do
something at least in the direction you
want it or or why would it make a
difference I think that it would be
helpful to have the mediation to help us
navigate difficult conversations and
then what if I'm wrong then there would
be an attorney present to say that's
really not something to be concerned
about or they might say yeah actually we
could take a look at that okay thank you
if you have anything else to say or you
that's all I have okay any questions for
her from the committee representative
maputi thank you uh Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so currently help
me understand currently the occup cural
licensing board is a regulatory board
and you would like to see The Advisory
convert that into Advisory board for two
reasons one is the regulation rule
making would be lot more friendlier not
non-competitive we're a small profession
and we don't get along
well okay uh and director Courtney just
quick um how many licensed AC licensed
by the acupuncher board just briefly
I'll have you up here in a bit but I
think
okay so it's so it's under 200 it's
under
the okay so the okay car follow the
second point is the Sherman versus North
Carolina act proved that there is fidu
uh Financial liability on the board on
the part of the board members if they
are regulatory board versus Advisory
Board that's your understanding that
that is my understanding okay can I ask
for a clarification with the I'm going
to have director Courtney but if you
have something brief that she could come
up now that's no go go from who from the
from Doug and attorney and Court uh when
they come next I'll have them up I was
going to let the the these two uh people
speak and answer any questions that are
specific to them and then we'll have the
oplc FKS up all right so you're done um
oh wait a minute you have a question
Rob yeah I do than you Mr representative
Brown could you just explain a little
bit more what you said about the
detoxification specialist there wasn't
one on the board now which currently
there is no ads ACU detox specialist on
the board but the acupuncture board is
made up of four acupuncturist and one
public member so there's no ACU detox
specialist currently
like right now the the law and maybe the
rules State it's for acupuncturist and a
public member now now is an AC just a
moment clarification is an acud detox
specialist considered an acupuncturist
so could they be on the
board they could probably fill the role
of a public member if they were asked to
me as one of the acupuncturist members I
don't believe so director Courtney
shaking her head so okay thank you sorry
yeah that's okay so you said something
about and I wasn't writing fast enough
the board approved rules for acupuncture
detox
specialist but you didn't the board
didn't have one on there to help them
put those together is that was that your
correct okay um uh Miss branstrom if I'm
pronouncing that correctly yes yeah
that's right uh I just want to Second
the piece about
excuse
me getting over a cold um second the
piece about the importance of having an
ads on the board um and having
representation for ads is in New
Hampshire um the I I have been doing
I've been certified and uh volunteering
as an ads since 2018 um it's a totally
different kind of unique genre of
acupuncture um uh we serve different
popul there's so many differences uh an
ads is doing more something that's more
akin to Street Outreach in a way you
know last year I set up a an ear
acupuncture clinic on the State House
lawn here for Recovery day um it's just
we serve different populations um uh
people who will go and see a licensed
acupuncturist cannot necessarily afford
or sorry vice versa people who will come
to get the notada protocol or ear
acupuncture cannot afford to see a
license so there's just so many
differences um different
interests uh historically licensed
acupuncturists have been very opposed to
allowing uh people like myself to be out
on the street doing the simple ear
protocol um so there's conflict there
and it yeah I I just want to stress the
importance of having representation on a
whatever the form the board may take any
questions from Miss branstrom represent
mapy um how recent is the specialty in
occupant occupant itself is an evolving
field and how recent is this uh specific
year detox uh occupant field it goes
back to the early 70s but I'll yeah yeah
it has yeah it's been going on for
decades in the US um and globally uh I
think 1974 was when in the Bronx in New
York City it was um kind of like uh
popularized as a movement um and then
the national ACC acupunctured
detoxification Association or NADA was
formed in the what the early 80s um so
it has a it has a robust history in the
US do you want to add I mean I would add
that we didn't have the certification of
acupuncture detoxification Specialists
here in New Hampshire until
2017 um but in some cases like if you
look at New York state New York City
where it was pioneered it was before
there were acupuncture laws and um when
acup when acupuncture statutes were
passed in the state of New York they did
it sort of acupuncturist came together
to wipe out the acupuncture
detoxification Specialists and get them
out of practice so there is a bit of a
contentious history there okay uh thank
you representative
gold thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question is there anything
in the way the current bill is this
current bill is written that you feel
needs to be changed at the moment no
thank you representative Brown thank you
Mr
chair uh it in the law now the board
consists of four
acupuncturists and one public member we
don't have a public member in suggested
in this legislation which would be right
in there right so on pay for everyone
for page one line 15 through 19 is the
makeup of the board
is
there I I guess I'll ask you folks since
you're sitting there do you are we
missing a public member is that
something we need to do and then maybe
the chair knows why that
happened from what I understand
listening to other hearings um oplc have
mentioned that it's hard to find public
members yeah thank you okay any other
questions that represent to follow up
with uh representative Brown
that typically you have three
members and if it is executive director
they have three members um and one of
which is to be an acupuncture
detoxification specialist current I mean
that's proposed the bill do you know I'm
going to ask director Courtney but do
you know off hand the current board
membership it's right here oh it's what
four
acupuncturists excuse me four
acupuncturists and one public member
okay thank you
um so in this sorry to follow up uh uh
so it's reducing from five to three
member board as an advisory
right um do you have any opinion on that
no okay thank you okay if uh nothing
else for for these uh ladies I'd like to
have uh the oplc folks up to answer any
you know provide some information answer
any questions and thank you both for
waiting oh yeah thank
you
thank you for taking the time out of
your day to be here I know they had to
ones okay so
um where to start I guess have you been
able to find the the P a public member
for this board is one question yes they
do have a longstanding public member um
typically The Advisory boards don't have
public members the theory being that
oplc can basically serve in that
function because they're not part of the
board
but you could certainly add a public
member um we don't take a position on
that I assume that if we were to add a
public member since you tend to like odd
numbers on the boards you'd want us to
add somebody else too correct five yeah
yeah five total okay um represent M py
um so to oplc thank you Mr chair uh for
oplc this has been an Advisory Board
from no
sorry occup puncture board has been an
Advisory Board no it's not the purpose
of this one of the the main purpose of
this section of the bill is to make it
an Advisory Board it's currently
statutory so let me repas a question
then so it's been a statutory board for
how
long I'd have to go back into the
rsas um I don't know off the top of my
head I can find that answer for you I
think one of the if my memory serves me
correct it was one of the first
alternative therapies that were board
licensed or board certified in New
Hampshire occup puncture was one of the
ones so
1997 correct okay effect yeah effective
yeah 20 1997 so one more followup Mr
chair yes so the detox acupuncture
didn't start until much later or once we
had unfortunately became the number two
overdose state in the country right I'm
looking at RSA 328 g9a and looks like
that statute originated in 2017 correct
so this is much more recent in terms of
okay all right just to follow up on that
so before that was that acupuncture
licensed at all or regulated yes so it
looks like acupuncturist have been
licensed since 1997 or 1998 right and
they added under the acupuncture board
um the acupuncture detox specialist in
2017 some states have put them in other
under other boards namely uh lak or
Alcohol and Other Drug use professionals
boards but it looks like we put them
under acupuncture and just follow so
prior to 2177 2017 would it have been
legal or illegal for someone to practice
the acupuncture detox that I don't know
I think the question would depend on
whether or not what they were doing was
considered acupuncture that's that's the
question so okay thank
you
um all
right so the other thing then I don't
see any other questions related what
we've done so far and I guess other than
going to the the the this section of the
bill other than the changes to the board
membership and the changes that were
necessary to change it from being a uh a
statutory to Advisory Board what if any
other changes are in here I haven't had
a chance to take a really detailed look
so I have a question for well I'd like
to get an answer to
this no no just no no I'm referring just
to the section on acupuncture so it
removes um statutory authority to Esta
rules for temporary lure of a visiting
acupuncture teacher yeah to my knowledge
we've never issued such a license and
those people would could be licensed
under the PLC 313 so it's not
necessary
um yeah that's why I'm looking to see
are we doing anything other than making
advisory and changing the board
membership no there's some cleanup
language that is intended to address
some of the legis ative changes we've
this body has made
previously um
but
no yes so so there's some cleanup
language related to the investigative
changes from last year right
okay
right yeah um page
22 uh it says instead of the board
executive director approved professional
trained in acq
25 strike um board is struck out and is
the uh Ru making Authority shifting from
occupant board that's what an Advisory
Board
means it the rule Mak
actual room making Authority let me find
that section um is with the oplc
director is with the oplc um in in
consultation with the board but but the
actual Authority is with the oplc and
that related to the problem that we had
in the past that she mentioned where um
the board was required by Statute to
create certain rules and they refused to
do so um oplc was because they were
advisory oplc was able to create the
rules that stat required whereas if
there were statutory board um that would
not have been possible unless so I have
one question regarding that Mr chair if
you can indulge me in sure yeah one of
the
um you know a issue about um needle
hygiene hygiene of the needle and the
certified um the course that the clean
needling techniques needling techniques
um is it similar with the for across
acupuncture or is it different for
different areas of specialty in
acupuncture does OPC know that I would
defer to the excert in the room who is
not myself I would say um this isn't
relevant to the bill and here's why I
mean I haven't seen a there there a
language in here that keeps the rules in
exist assistance that are there now um
to start yes it's I'm sorry it's on page
one yeah I think line six and seven
right now I have a I have a comment
about that purpose paragraph it seems
like it's it's added under the
acupuncture it is added under
acupuncture but it seems like it could
be the purpose of the whole bill but I
guess that's another conversation yeah
there and then I was going to get to
that um some people are uncomfortable
and on the full committee at least are
uncomfortable with with to eliminate
Workforce barriers and provide State
supervision over regulatory bodies
compares to Market
participants um I know certain members
of the full committee have an issue at
least with the first part of that to
right and and it is in every one of
these yeah and I am fine taking we can
make a a motion for an amendment to take
that out everywhere and that that point
I wanted to make is that acupuncture is
an Allied Health profession but at the
same time it's a penetrative like a
needle being injected right the safety
that's my Public Safety hat comes in and
but this is still going to require
licensing for everybody who has to have
licensing now and the rules going to
stay the same and the detox Specialists
are covered under here and there is
required training so I don't think this
bill would change any of that unless
oplc goes crazy and decides they're
going to remove that requirement which
you know rule making somebody would
raise an issue if she lost her mind so
not that I'm
suspecting my one last question in that
is it customary to say replacing the
board with executive director or is it
board p on mine please this is page
two
line one at the 10 yeah that's Lang
that's language in every Advisory Board
in statute
today right the board replacing board
with the executive director is it
not that's what changes if the Advisory
Board and all the advisory boards that
existence today have that language I
think your question though is whether it
should be executive director or office
and the typical way of doing that in
state government because the
commissioner is responsible for
administration of the office is to
identify the commissioner who then
delegates that Authority right she
doesn't or I'm I'm just thinking is is
it should be
oplc office of no no because you need a
person who a state official responsible
for executing an implementing the job
and implementing the statute and and
since she's the head of oplc it ends up
saying it's executive director means
oplc basically
okay repres Brown Y and and somewhere
that should have that should follow
through so usually somewhere back in
statute it says the
oplc and it identifies the executive
director and then every time you see
executive director it it means that same
thing I think it's RSA 310 that sets up
oplc would have that in there and I
think so I I see page one line 25 the
executive director in consultation with
the board shall adopt rules is this
under RSA
541a that's the standard Ru making for
all legislation and so that means that
she'd consult with the board they'd come
up with rules not her necessarily
personally but somebody works for her
and then that's got to go out for public
comment they take public comment they
have to have a public hearing and you
know maybe change the rules based on
that with the input they get and then it
goes before the joint legislative
committee on rules which will review it
and uh and that's that whole process
so
meance I know you're new to Ed but
you'll see 541a through most of our
stuff and that's what means no I'm just
looking at checks and balances in terms
of you know not one Authority yeah she
can't on her own come up with rules and
they become law on our own um it's
there's a lot of process to that which
is which it should be okay uh
representative gold would you like a
motion to uh remove that language um in
each of the sections of this bill sure
and so this is an amendment
now do you want to remove
moove just to eliminate Workforce
barriers uh and remove that um or and
basically to CH to to change it to to to
provide State supervision over
regulatory bodies comprised of active
Market participants because that's the
removing the issues of the board
liability or reducing it and the
concerns about um antitrust suit and
just remove eliminate workfor barriers
and the word and or do you want to
remove the whole sentence up to the
comma I just want to get idea of her
motion and then we can we can discuss we
can discuss thank
you well I could be flexible with it um
but if the wording to eliminate
Workforce
barriers is an obstacle to getting the
bill passed then my motion would be to
remove that line
um yeah so it would be to remove to it
would remove the words eliminate
Workforce barriers and correct and and I
think it's the same elsewhere but if
it's worded slightly differently it
would be basically to make it consistent
all the way through all right so uh
remove
words eliminate Workforce barriers and
provide oh
and eliminate Workforce barriers and and
um uh and this would be throughout the
bill
correct you oppose that okay so I I I'll
second it actually so this is uh Gould
and we can have then let me write this
discussion and I think representative
Brown was first and then representative
Bailey yep so not every single one of
these advisory boards has a purpose
statement but a few of them do and let's
see let's start with
I made my note here so page six on line
2329 well there's more of the purpose
starting at line 20 but that's an
existing law so several a couple of them
say to reduce work force barriers not
eliminate and maybe that's a better
wording but the the purpose here is
worded pretty
differently than it is on
I and I guess it's fair each board could
have a different purpose stated I
suppose right I mean I I would take this
when I went to OLS and did the amendment
that on page and we could do them
individually but I if I understand the
idea page
six uh starting at line 23 yeah I would
um I would just remove to reduce
Workforce barriers and promote
efficiency and economy and just have it
start with the responsibility for
invitations chapter shall be
transferred right I would take and and
here's there is Mr chair if you see the
20 line 20 to
23 is the original language and the
bolded one refers to Workforce barriers
right I'm saying is to take on the
bolded language to remove
everything up to the
responsibility
because the responsibility is stating
what this would do and and here's an
actually
um but really I should let you first
speak about your motion then I'll speak
and then anybody else is the process and
I don't mind going through each one but
honestly on line 23 on page six if we
remove reduced Workforce barriers and
and it says to promote efficiency and
economy the responsibility for
implementation of this chapter shall be
transferred to the director uh to the
executive director of The Office of
professional licensure and certification
I don't see anything wrong with right I
mean if you're we could go through one
by one but if you're okay with I mean I
understand what you want to do so that
one my my take on that one is that the s
that sentence would start with the
responsibility for implementation and
leave the preperatory Clause out that's
fine okay and and a question on that
sure well let me speak a little bit
about why I want I mean I don't have a
problem with those clauses I don't
disagree with them but I know they make
some people they strike some people on
the full committee as um not com they're
not comfortable with it and I don't
think they add any value um other than
saying why the bill was brought forward
they don't add any value to the to the
actual thing and why keep something that
people are going to be uncomfortable
with so my question and actually would
um represent Bailey had asked to speak
first and then M well we hear often that
the purpose of these licenses is to
protect the public and but sometimes I
hear things that suggest that we do
think of these licenses as a guild and
that's pretty obvious that this is not a
guild it's to reduce Workforce barriers
right I don't just I don't think it
hurts anything but I think it underlines
the main point this is for saving lives
not for establishing a
right I don't as I said I don't disagree
with that I'm just looking at uh as a
practical sense of getting support for
it that's all so I mean you don't have
to vote for
it uh go on sorry and maybe one of the
ones that spoke sorry did you say me uh
I think represent mipi had a pending
question Mr chair um there were some
responsibility was uh when oplc got the
licensing uh
responsibility last
year it included all these boards right
it's the shift now what we are looking
at it's not so much the
workforce barrier or it's more changing
the board who has a regulatory
responsibility who has a uh Ru making
responsibility by changing the board
from
advisory to whichever
way yeah so my general position on lure
is that it's
a necessary barrier to
Workforce if to protect the public so
that's the only legitimate reason to
license somebody um but it is a barrier
because you're requiring somebody to
take an affirmative step and if you have
procedures in place and criteria in
place that actually is not related to
protecting the public then that becomes
an unnecessary barrier so when we talk
about antitrust issues Market
participants some of the concern is that
maybe some of the lure criteria is not a
necessary barrier to protect the public
because it's completely unrelated or
doesn't establish minimum competencies
so if that's the case then yes I would
definitely say that the purpose
statement makes sense to reduce work
first barriers cuz what you're saying is
we're going to cut out all of the extra
stuff that is not necessary to protect
the public and make sure that the only
thing we're asking for is necessary to
competency so can I just follow up with
that one so you're saying we are R
lowering the threshold for Public Safety
no what I'm saying is here's an example
with the acupuncture board with the PLC
313 which is implementing the statute
from last year so the rules that were
referenced by Miss Rob were our rules
and so we received her comments and were
able to adjust them because they were
our rules the conversation that I had
with the board of acupuncture was you
know they should have our rulle said you
should have this level of Education this
level of training um pay this fee their
comments were largely centered around
things that I don't think are necessary
to protect the public like
the other state should ensure that they
are that applicants are required to
submit a passport photograph in order to
get licensed and if that state doesn't
require that then we should not find
that state has substantially similar
requirements I don't think that
submitting a passport photograph is
necessary to protect the public and I
actually think it promotes implicit bias
in the licensing evaluation process and
so I did not take those comments and
include that in and and make changes in
the proposal so those are the type of
things that we're talking about
um by eliminating those what I consider
to be unnecessary requirements you are
entry
um okay so we have a
motion um this is to well we have a
first of all whether these words are in
here or not does not change the effect
of the statute whatsoever and
representative Courtney is that I mean
not representative I'm I'm going to cut
your pay too now uh director Courtney um
volunteer position yeah that's right I
don't think she's crazy enough to
volunteer um no the qu my statement is
removing that language from the purpose
statements is not going to have any
operational effect in in how the board
the whole oplc works or the boards
correct the only thing that I think we
do need is is this language that I know
this committee was um interested in um
is requiring the executive director to
consult with The Advisory board when
implementing the chapters and then
keeping the language that says rules in
effect um in effect on the effective
date that is what we would need from an
operation standpoint okay and I'm not
proposing we're not proposing changing
that so okay um so we have a motion to
eliminate the words we've discussed from
anywhere in this bill
and I'd like to take a vote um all those
in
favor I okay anyone
opposed okay that's fine oh you are as
well okay later on we can I'm curious as
to why no discussion is closed
discussion is closed let me let me uh
yeah right um no no I just want to
record
this one two anyway it's three what just
a moment yeah um three to two so um the
committee has I haven't voted yet yep oh
sorry no
sorry what are the words because it's
different throughout the document so
again so the word the words um the words
that are the effect of eliminate
Workforce barriers um that part of it or
in page six it was a little more
extensive uh reduce Workforce barriers
and promote efficiency in economy taking
words of that sort out wherever
they're in here I found a few more
instances I'm sure there are more if you
would like me to that' be great give
them is that just email to I don't know
unless you want to talk to well just and
so people see that
are reluctant to support it on page 11
if you look at line
28 we would remove reduce Workforce
barriers and provide State supervision
well the state supervision We need oh
yeah to reduce it's so it's just reduce
work force barriers and and right that's
what I would do yep I and I like the way
that one's written but and so that's all
we're removing is redu that offensive to
some people language we really are back
into so I'm yes so if we move the
language to reduce Workforce barriers or
and to eliminate Workforce barriers then
I'm a yes okay so the vote is 3 to2 and
that will be in included in we'll have a
probably a final vote on the amendment
but procedural question Mr uh Mr chair y
if the two members if if some of the
members who voted no didn't understand
what we were voting on then somebody can
make a vote to
reconsider I I'm not saying I don't
understand what it is but we'll have
another opportunity at the full
committee to look at and the
subcommittee is going you know it is
passing the by the way these votes are
not am I yeah these votes um they're
just guiding you to write an amendment
but if we leave it in there if we don't
put it in the amendment and then we had
the floor go back we're wasting o o
whatever the lawyers downstairs time no
I I mean I guess the question is and
this is just general discussion um if
there's anybody who voted no on this who
um that would prevent them from if they
agreed otherwise from voting on the full
amendment to support of the full
Amendment GL
we have two more chances right one is
the full committee we have to vote and
have a discussion as a sub committee as
well we have another like we did last
time on 1410 we'll have a now hopefully
if people have an issue we know before
that but yeah yeah and and uh I think
that would help in having a cleaner
Amendment with what's removed and to see
it
and trying to think of process here I'm
I mean if there's anybody who is
interested in changing how their vote
their vote how they voted given the
discussion we had during the vote which
was not quite appropriate maybe um they
can make a motion to reconsider we can
do that um
otherwise um all I'm asking is I just
need a yes or no answer that's it if we
C make this amendment taking those words
out
is will that prevent anyone from voting
on the final Amendment if they agree
Amendment it
um all right we'll we'll let's let's set
this aside for the moment and I we'll
talk separate and
decide I I do have a suggestion yes uh
real quickly so if you look at page 25
25 starting on line
one that it doesn't say that it's a
purpose statement but I like I like so
what's in the law already reads very
well I think the general court to
protect the health safety and Welfare of
the people of New Hampshire EST as a
regulatory program from XYZ page 25
starting at the top starting at the top
so the non-bold is what's in the law now
and I think that's well said and then
it then the the remainder of it reflects
the other the others that we have okay
so here here's what I I'd like to do um
clearly we're going to have to meet
again on this bill so um I'd like
representative Gould and anyone else who
wants to to um look through here and
find all the places where there's
similar language and I'd like that
emailed out just to the subcommittee
members okay and if anybody has a a a
suggestion for
um alternate language for those places
like maybe you know what's already in
statute that and if every you know send
that out an email to the to all just the
subcommittee we don't need to confuse
the full committee on it and then in a
later meeting we can discuss what we
want to do and and we can you know the
sort of informal vote we just took We
could decide we want to do something
different
okay excellent excellent so um so I
would
I'll make a motion just to move things
along and this is an amendment well it's
not really an amendment it's just our
intent and that is uh
keep um you know this the part one um on
acupuncture so keep the changes to
acupuncture y um with whatever decision
we just make on the um changes to
the per you know the purpose language
but but to keep that in the bill so that
we would actually uh move the board of
acupuncture
to um an Advisory Board second okay and
so that's
luus second by
gold okay um do we need more discussion
we've spent a while on this I mean can
we go to a vote all in
favor anyone
opposed right to accepting the language
that's in that part of the bill dealing
with
acupuncture except we may change the
purpose State and as part of the general
redo of that yeah okay and so the vot
vote is anyone opposed that's five to
zero okay thank you um so then there's a
a practical
question um it's approaching one o'clock
I know some people need lunch some
people have issues with not going too
long with without food so and I know
there's at least one member that needs
to be out of here she's not not
necessarily the only one and uh and we
need to and there's someone here who
needs to leave at
2:30 who would do that who would do that
and the thing is if we left now for
lunch we wouldn't be back until 1:45 to
and so and I don't want to and I don't
know what your situation is as far as
how long you folks can hang around they
live here they live here you certainly
may we talked about um when next
Wednesday when the in the morning in the
morning if we can uh put this one at
subcommittee yeah Wednesday morning okay
um so first of all well actually why
don't you ask your question
so and actually what I'm going to do if
we're not going to to continue today I
will close the subcommittee work session
and then we can have that so people are
freed up um so if if people agreed we're
not going to uh continue today I'm going
to close the subcommittee um work
session on House Bill
1271 thank what unless you have I I have
a question so we know the acupuncture
board was concerned and they were here
I'm reopening it we heard sorry we've
heard from a lot of other boards but no
one else is here today uh do we have any
any stomach for just no going Opa now uh
on the whole bill with the change to
yeah on the whole bill with the changes
to the purpose I I would be okay with
that but similar to what I said when we
started this section
um I question
whether um that would be good even
assuming everybody here agreed it'd be
questioned you know whether that would
be an issue although I don't know that's
fair yeah that's fair I I would say you
know we are taking too many votes before
we are com at least you know I don't
feel comfortable just saying okay fine
we looked at this section and the rest
of the I mean it's a 42 Page Bill my
question is my question is are you
willing to sit and look go through the
family mediator section now and not wait
till Wednesday
morning we could do do that or we you
know we still have other votes right I'm
not asking you to vote on the whole bill
I'm asking you will you do the next
section now can we can we stick around
to do the next section is that your
question sure I can to make some more
progress I can okay okay in that case
we'll continue and uh the F folks here
actually we did vote to um to do the
changing of the acupuncture board to
advisor it's not final so will take a
vote on the full Amendment then the
committee and the house the St and
everything but but for today uh you're
welcome to stay and watch this what
we're doing but uh I don't but if we're
not going to have anything else for you
if you'd like to leave and thank
seriously thank you for spending the
morning with us and into the afternoon
actually
okay do bring that it isn't good what's
the issue the repeal of the that but
it's already 14 no no no no no no no
that's part of this
um it we're let's look at
the I didn't know if you knew off the
top of your head no no it's it needs to
be what's the what I wrote Hang four
it's already see that that gets rid of
G6 um we have a okay uh we're going to
we're going to continue but a brief
question still on the acupuncture one
just a technical thing um what page is
what 6 line 9 page six
yeah I think we're fine but I had made a
note before that it's already in
1410 but I I can't no but that's
acupuncture 1410 was U um medical
different but 14 1410 didn't deal with
medical with with acupuncture whatsoever
I don't think uh professional
um 328
G6 would have
g
SN I think I looked at that enough I
think I would have caught it all right
um so this is what we're dealing with
here if people are ready to move for
forward um this section starts at Page 6
line 11 through Page
11 line
18 and what I would like to do it's got
the thing about the workforce barriers
which you know we we're dealing with
separately so I don't want to get into
that on this section Mr chair it's not
911 it's line we are looking at the
family mediator 19
it's page six line 11 am
I 19 oh no I probably it's all I
probably made a mistake L 19 okay thank
you for the correction I will
notes6 oh yeah I messed up thank you all
right I have a fundamental question
okay
um to I okay uh director
coordin is this an Advisory board right
a did it it's a regulatory board right
now yes correct it's an independent
regulatory board and I can tell you
currently
has
they had two meetings last year in
November they cancelled all but two of
their
meetings how often do they
meet they had two meetings last
months and I if my memory serves me
correctly they have 47 lenses I can
confirm that for you number and
our main concern is that there are
Quorum issues there have historically
been Quorum issues that said we did just
get a new member many of these
appointments are not by the governor so
that's another part of the challenge we
did just get another judicial
appointment and they're very you know
they're very
engaged um
but but yes that's the primary issue and
I don't recall any um uh opposition
coming from any family mediators to this
bill I don't recall seeing any um three
member board five so yeah what is the
what is the current membership of the
board and how would this part of the
bill change it it's good good question
so I see corrected they have
37 lenes 37 no it's even worse and one
two three five member board okay and uh
what what would this does this make
changes the board I'm sorry for it does
so yeah three
page thank you and it also changes who
appoints one of the judges that I
saw yeah it changes from five to three
yeah can you talk about the changes and
board so I think the idea was to reduce
the number of board members to be
consistent with the number of board
members we typically see on advisory
boards um so the first one was one judge
who regularly sits in the Circuit Court
Family Division currently appointed by
just judge king the administrative judge
of the Circuit Court um I'm not sure why
this was change to the Chief Justice I
think it could be either
way um the second one was uh essentially
removing the public member so there's
there would no longer be a public member
and that again that's typical for
advisory boards that's that's typical
the next change is there's currently a
requirement that there be a member of
the New Hampshire Bar Association which
is basically any attorney who's licensed
in New Hampshire but um we added
specializing in family law
matters because Family Mediation you
know it seems to make sense that you
have that
experience and then rather than having
three certified family members who
historically have been nominated by
associations
which I I personally find problematic
just generally because associations the
purpose of an association is to promote
the profession and the purpose of a
regulatory board is to protect the
public and they don't always H share the
same objectives so when you have an
association in Vermont it's actually if
you're not ethically Pro allowed to be
on a board of an association and on a
regulatory board um so I find it
problematic when associations are doing
the appointments because they're likely
to find members who are going to further
their objectives while being on the
regulatory board so anyways um this was
changed from um 3 to one and then
eliminating the nomination by the
Association so
um just I i' like a follow up then I'll
go back to you if that's all right um so
having the New Hampshire bar in there as
the association is okay because they're
not supposedly presumably don't have an
interest in Family Mediation directly
the whole organization or right so this
goes back to our earlier conversation
off the Record which is that every
attorney is required to be a member of
the bar association it's not a voluntary
Association but um I guess
the you know it I guess the question is
is there some
organization other than the bar that
might be better to do it but then I
don't know it's better than giving them
all to you to appoint I suppose or I
mean you could have the Supreme Court
appoint them they are technically the
regulatory body for for
attorneys who they've essentially
um outsourced some of that function to
the bar association but you could
certainly have the Supreme Court do it
I'm not objecting I'm just uh wondering
okay representative maputi um I just
have to go back to a statement you made
about the association being a member or
Board of uh you know a board member on
an association in my profession I had to
be a board member I mean not board
member I had to be a member of an
association in order to be licensed in
order to be certified in state and like
the speech and hearing Association Asha
you had to be a member later on it was
changed that you don't have to be a
member but you have to pay dues to the
membership and so there are different
professions
where being a member of an association
will not you can't have a license
correct me if I'm wrong but this doesn't
prohibit somebody being a member of the
association from being on the board it's
just the association can't pick them is
that correct yeah I think there are two
different issues here there those are
essentially Association board
certifications if you will what we're
talking about is let's say you have the
New Hampshire Medical Society which is
the professional association for
Physicians um if you are on that board
of directors and your job and your fiary
responsibility is to promote the
profession and you are also on a
regulatory board and your job is to
protect the public they don't always
meet in the middle and so you can be a
member of the medical society but you
shouldn't have the fiduciary
responsibility as a board member to
promote the profession and then also be
on a regulatory board because there
could be a conflict of interest that's
that's what we're talking about
okay it's not okay I I'll figure it out
okay I think the key is it doesn't
prohibit the person appointed being a
member of the association it's just the
association doesn't pick up
representative Brown thank you Mr
chair so in the cases where that isn't
the case you're getting uh nominations
are you getting sugest how do you get
nominations then suggestions suggestions
you you kind of canvas the the the
industry or if it fall right so it's
going to fall back to oplc if there's no
one nominating if I'm reading it right
we've taken out nominated by the by the
Association then you're doing the
nominations yeah so typically we send
out email blast to all lenses to give
everyone an opportunity to submit an
application they put an application and
then we look at it for experience and
their ability to commit to the volunteer
time is essentially what it looks like I
just got to C for us um one other
question and that is on page eight um
the second line it
um you can't
it is it it says you can't serve more
than two consecutive terms which I'm
fine of what what was it before was
there no limit which is kind of said
that the acupun not more yeah it looks
like there was um it depended on who you
appointed by so earlier there was some
language if you're appointed by the
court it would be up to the court or the
administrative judge how long your
length was and then if you're appointed
by the governor um you eligible to serve
more than three full consecutive terms
that's just administratively difficult
for us to manage you know who's up when
if it's just at the uh determination of
a person and not something that we put
in the red book okay and I I agree that
I mean this would let somebody serve for
six years which probably is shouldn't be
longer than that I I guess my only
practical question is given the number
of people involved in this is there
going to be any problem finding people
to
serve if they can't serve more than two
consecutive
terms that's hard to say I mean
currently there's
37 lenses I would hope they would be
able to find one out of those 37 who
hadn't previously served and this
wouldn't prevent somebody who'd served
before from serving again later right
correct all right thank you uh
representative maputi um I do have a
comment and uh that is I understand the
intention of opening it up to all the
licy that you have access
to but don't you think it's the
association is in a better position to
nominate somebody not the board member
Association board member but Association
member
to propose a board member to this oplc
board Advisory Board personally I don't
think so because they're going to pick
somebody that is going to likely has an
interest in what the association is
doing and I think opening it up to
everybody give everybody an opportunity
to participate is is more in line with
uh what we at state government should be
doing there there's another practical
issue here I don't think that make can
work because if an association is going
to make a recommendation that can only
be by a vote of the board because the
board represents the association any
random member in the
association can't represent the
association they can put themselves
forward as an
individual no I I didn't say they will
be represent board members will nominate
but the association can recommend an
individual member to the board for
oplc that yeah and that would uh that
gets back to the conflict of interest
thing
no no it gets back to the conflict of
interest issue if I'm No it's it's
similar to what uh director Courtney
blasting to 37 members to say who is
ready to vote I may not even know that a
board exists let me let me ask so
there's nothing to prevent the
association from sending you a letter
recommending anybody no we don't need to
have in statute for them to be able to
do it correct okay if there is
opportunity that's fine yeah there is
the the distinction is that um under the
scenario that's currently existing we
can't send out an email blastic the
inform the recommendation can or the
nomination can only come from the
association I have another question uh
representative Brown thank you Mr chair
so another question about that
particular line page eight line two uh
no member shall be appointed to more
than two consecutive terms on page one
on line 18
under acupuncturist it says more than
two consecutive full terms I don't know
if we want to make that consistent
matters yeah this actually comes up a
lot when somebody resigns midterm and
the question is whether or not they get
they just have to finish out the
person's prior term and then gets
another full term I mean so I would say
full term to make it clear thank you all
right uh no more than two consecutive
full terms wherever that shows up in
this yeah and if if we notice it
anywhere else we can do the same okay is
there other than changing um the board
membership and how they are
selected and making this and I see
there's something about you know
electing the chairman is there anything
else in
here that makes any change other than
those necessary for making it an
Advisory
Board is it doing anything else what
n Mr chair I'd like to get answer this
and I'll sorry have my mic on I'm sorry
deletions on page nine seem like that
has to do with the changes we've made to
oplc already
Yes 23 to really I I really want to not
do anything further until I get an
answer to
this I I want to hear a verbal answer
but there may be other yes that's
correct that deals with the time frames
for for Li Insurance certification that
we adjusted last session okay and then
is there anything else in you know this
area part of the bill that makes any
change other than the ones we've
discussed other than the ones for making
Board
Mr chair um yes in this it says board is
crossed page page in line page nine I'm
just seeing board is crossed offine
office line is six the first one and
it's consistent board is crossed off
offic is in place but in occupy uh
occupant thing it was said no we we
executive director so there's no
consistency
I would agree with that what I would
agree I think it I personally I
think the better approach is to say
executive director because the
commissioner has responsibilities under
other
rsas but thank you for okay but I thank
you for that back to the original
question is there anything else getting
changed in here other than the
membership and voting for a chair and
making an
advisory uh and and the no please and
the and the cleaner I was going to get
to your question okay yeah and then to
the point you brought
up
um so I guess the thing is what areas in
this part of this
bill um so you pointed out where it went
from board to line six see actually on
on page n yeah line 8 it's not
consistent
line8 page 8 line 33 it does go Board of
executive director but um all on page
nine yeah so actually yeah starting oh
was it six 9 is it all right six 9 11 11
12 yep
16 y 18 oh jeez Y and also 35 and 35 and
let me see forther on page 10 line page
10 line 16 same issue uh line oh yep
there
is um line 24 on page 10 theor with it
but no that's fine that's fine Y and
then on the next
page oh it does use executive director
instead of board in the two places on
line 11 it's not consistent somebody
somebody needs to go and whacko aess up
the side of the head but their lowercase
here and they were all board and
executive director where uppercase in
the first
instance hang hang on no no this is one
amendment that written it once they took
the Lang no no I don't think that's the
issue so okay so which ones the very
first instance back on page eight okay
page eight line 33 line
whoops um
yeah was that it no that 33 that page 8
33 right I think you're saying page 8
line 33 executive director capitalize
throughout it is
lowerre there's a very specific reason
for that that I can't tell it's in a
title it's in the title of the section
so it's capitalized thank you all right
um
so um okay people can look through and
are there do we just
change instead of saying board to office
um board to executive director in all
those
places I'm thinking the answer is yes
yes yes
yes well know I'm only looking at this
one and as we go through the other ones
if we find similar problems we'll deal
with them then I'm sure there are
similar problems I'm sure there are so
just say we're going to do that for 46 I
I'm insisting as chair we're going to do
it this way because there's only so much
I can deal with in one chunk one last
clarification about the term yeah so is
there a difference between the statutary
board versus uh Advisory board if there
is less than six months left if somebody
resigns almost at the end of the
term to be replaced or you know um more
than six months
left we usually just replace them as as
they resign I mean it typically takes
time to replace them um
but we just replace we
just okay I'm not sure if that answers
your question I'm sorry
representative there's no difference
thank
you okay I don't know that we need take
does anyone have any objection in the
section on family mediators to change um
you know where it go where it currently
goes from office just board to office to
executive director are there any
objections okay I don't think we need to
actually record a vote or anything
so when I put a final Amendment together
I made a note we'll do that okay cool
um so I think we've gone through this
we've
discussed the big issue which is well
making advisory and also the
appointments to the
um okay and so I'm uh looking for a
we accept the changes made in this
meeting to hb1
1271 to section 12 family mediators
board hang on it's it's actually
multiple sections hang but but line you
can just say if you want starting page
six line 19
through 1118
through Page 11 line
five um let me see if that's right I had
I had more but I could be
wrong uh no it it goes down to to
18 and we have to have those parts in
because they're changing the RSA r
and they're they're repealing the old
stuff those parts are all okay that's
fine those those sections are in are
part of the me I got it okay right so
yes I will amend that amendment to page
11 line 18 okay so this is again uh page
six
[Music]
line line 19 y
19 no page page six page six line 19
yeah yeah page six line 19 page 11 page
line 18 18 that's it's confusing so
changes with the changes uh discussed
discussed and and voted on and so you
know the final version will be after we
do the final dealing with the the
purpose
language um okay good
thank you and thanks to representative
goul for suggesting we move forward yes
and I'm happy to hear we've also moved
on from repealing repeals to amending
[Laughter]
amendments ah okay um so do we want to
continue on through another one yes so
anyone have an issue with doing that
okay that would start and that then is
Page anybody have a problem with that I
don't want to keep people from food if
they need need it and all that I'm good
okay um I'll give you a moment on that
because I don't want to push people past
what's a good
idea um so this is Page 11 line
19 through Page
20 um line 15 if I'm correct
11 to page 20 line 15 this is a
big um chunk that's correct and
um so and thank you for going through
and looking at more detailed markup than
I did I appreciate it what I got to do
my brain all right so um just looking at
this starting at page 11 at the
beginning page 11 uh line uh
line um
19 okay so the first part down
here it's what does it say
adding one correction
yeah page 20 what line did you say it it
lines 15 I believe yep
yep starts
right so um so at the beginning of this
the first
section
um says so it makes advising the
executive director concerning
implementation chapter there's another
reduced Workforce barriers and the edce
Workforce barriers which I will we'll
we'll deal with but I'll come up with a
proposal limiting
that
um rule it's got the part rules
inexistent will remain in effect until
repealed repealed by the executive
director of the so do you can repeal
them is that like okay the ru making
Authority would transfer to us so we
would have to repeal the old boards
rules so this basically just says
whatever rules are in existence stay in
existence until we take action on them
okay and that action presumably would be
proposing updated rules appeals and then
you have to go through the whole 541a
thing correct okay just a quick thought
y Mr chair sure think in uh trying to
reduce the workforce barrier and making
this smooth I hope we won't burn burn
out giving all the
responsibility director Court
we're going to have to we're going to
have to have discussion on the
subcommittee about that I think we're
done today with that one but I don't
think yeah I don't think that's going to
Happ that's not and it doesn't change
that taking whether we leave that
language out or take it in does not
change anything I think and correct me
about her job or what oplc does or
anything no although if you want to
raise my salary I'd be happy to accept
that statutory change um that that's my
job on a different committee I am
chairing uh The Joint Committee on
employee classification oh wonderful but
but you'd have to you'd have to so are
you the department head for that are you
under something else yes you'd have to
come and present a and go to the
consultant get a recommendation and then
I but with my different hat on I'd have
to consider that no didn't no no uh uh
there's the conflict of interest no I'm
just no no I'm not going to be paying
myself and I'm not and I'm not
individually making the whole payment so
I think it's diffuse enough so she's out
but I'm still in right I just want to be
clear I have no conflict I'm
not I'm I'm not uh indicating my view on
any of that right now different
hat okay sorry I you have to it's
afternoon we getting a little silly but
um okay so I think if everybody is uh is
okay with
proceeding um all right the next we get
to the usual thing was the board
membership
and this is drastic uh yeah so could you
give us an overview of the membership
change and then we can look at it I
suppose in some
detail yeah so currently there are many
many members on the guardian atlm board
um
and at least in the recent history this
board has had issues with Quorum he only
met two times last year um um so as
proposed this is reducing the membership
to three individuals consistent with how
it is from other advisory boards and
would be removing the legislatively
appointed members So currently there are
members appointed by the president of
the Senate and by the
speaker um the executive director of the
judicial Council also has a seat on the
board and so this uh bill is proposing
to remove
that um just are there any other boards
that have members appointed by the uh
president of the senate or speaker of
the house it's it's fairly rare we do
have we do have a couple of other boards
that unfortunately are not coming to my
mind right now that's okay just but we
do have a couple of other ones I will
say we don't currently have a House
member appointed which is which is a
problem part of the
problem um again one member of Casa
changing it from being appointed by the
governor to the executive director which
is consistent with uh advisory boards
and then um one member of eliminating
the DCF member um appointed by the
governor and then
um yeah that's I was wondering
so and also the the member of DCF or
representing them or Casey Family
Services is that what is Casey no Casey
Casey is um
um basically an entity don't correct me
if I'm wrong but that contracts with DCF
to provide certain services so they're
basically a private outfit that we
contract with that's my yeah they're not
a state body correct okay that seems a
little but miss
uh and and let me I'm trying to get
through this and then we go to other
people so with the board
membership I'm I really
please please suspend I want to get
through this and then I'll go to you if
if that I mean because you're
interrupting the stuff I'm trying to do
here so thank
you I'm just I a series of questions
about these things and then I'll move on
so what is actually court appointed
special Advocates one member of that
what is that organization or whatever it
is Doug do you want to chime in they're
the they're essentially the major entity
that um trains and
trains guard at Liams and then contracts
with the court uh to provide G's and
cases is that a New Hampshire outfit or
national or I think they're National but
they have they have a New Hampshire but
I don't want to misspeak but I think
that's my understanding aren't they the
advocates for children in court and
their
publicly that's the guardian please we
would have to go to recognizing people I
we've been pretty pre-form and I'm
normally okay with that but I'm just
trying talking about the C CA I'm asking
you not to speak until you're recognized
which I really don't want to have to do
but um and then the the the large
section here
removed oh you're taking the public the
rest of this is about public members
from lines 12 to
um and the removing members of board
should serve without compensation is cu
they do receive a per DM okay how how
much is that by the way this is It's
nominal it's $25 for them thank
you um and I'm just going to get through
the rest of this all members of they
shall be New Hampshire residents fine
and what's so each appointment should be
valid for three years to a successor the
term the member of Casa shall expire if
she okay if they're not member of Casa
so they're not they're not
eligible no more than two terms and if
they're they're they're d uh yeah
actually that's right um where is that
here so on line 23 on page 12 should
that be full terms to full terms yes
that let's see I got to make a
note page 12 I end up leaving or
not
L okay um all right I'm I'm done I was
just trying to get through all of this
and see how it worked so represent
maputi two points removing
dcyf
and the part of
the Guardian at leam Advisory Board
pertains to a lot of that with the dcyf
cases and public and children and Kasa
is also part of children being an
advocate and I think not having
representation from dcyf
or giving the whole thing to Kasa I
would say the checks and balances are
imbalanced so we won't take a position
on that but one thing I would note is
that in a court case right the G is
supposed to be neutral and is is
basically going out to get the
information on behalf of the Court DCF
is one party to the case and then you
have the parent so if you're going to
have CF you don't have somebody
representing the parents interests that
may be something for you to consider I
don't think it's personally necessary in
dealing with ler because really the
question is are they minimally competent
and you have G's on The Advisory board
that can help make that determination so
we're not really talking about um big
picture you know the role of the G in
the court system that's just something
you may want to consider because it
could be considered lopsided
all right so my point is not out out
there I I see it as a lopsided or not
fairly balanced yep you mean lopsided
now or lopsided if DCF are on I was just
saying that if you have DCF without the
parent I mean because DCF is a party to
the case yes parent you know the parent
is the party to the case the G is kind
of in the Middle where the judge sits so
if you add the DCF and don't have a
parent representative one can make the
argument that you're not fully
represented in the trifecta of the court
case and if I just a moment and and as
as it's in this bill do you think it's
not um well you've got essentially two
G's and a member of the court I I think
that those people are part of the
neutral um position in a courtroom so
you can start adding on different people
to represent different
perspectives but you would want to make
sure you capture them equally would be
my recommendation representative Brown
so I thank you Mr chair your casa
Advocate is supposed to
be neutral between parents and dcyf for
the children if I'm remembering that
correctly correct so they're they're a
neutral Advocate that that's their
that's their their job basically to do
that for the kids right so I think
that's a that's a fair one to have in
there okay uh representative gold thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question having this been my
life um working in child welfare for so
many
decades so I understand the casa can you
explain to me what one member
representing the interests of Guardian
at items
is I honestly don't know um and I
currently don't make the appointments so
I find that a little strange the way
it's currently worded it's bizarre
because it doesn't mean necessarily that
the person is a j no it could be anybody
representing their interests I would
suggest maybe making the change to just
one
gal so here's here's what I would say
about this historically we didn't have
cassa and cassa came along and they are
an international organiz I mean mean a
National Organization or they they're
bigger than New Hampshire it's not a
local group they do train Guardian Ed
items from
volunteers prior to that we had all
lawyers so the parents had a lawyer the
state had a lawyer and the kid had a
lawyer and the kids lawyer the guardian
at lium was appointed to represent the
child's best interest with full legal
knowledge and understanding of the law
cassa provided a much cheaper
alternative of people who did not
understand the law and the child lost
their legal representation that was
focused only on them and if you think
I'm biased I think I just made it clear
I was
and so cassa has worked really hard
everybody's loved it a lot of us
have shut up and moved on but this other
member I would ask there are still
attorneys who judges do appoint and very
specialized cases that are complicated
that really need an attorney and I would
request that that person
be a practicing gal who is an attorney
and is independent from cassa so we
don't just get two CA
volunteers on
there makes sense to me if you're asking
my opinion um could you suggest some
exact language if we were to do that yes
we can definitely put together some
draft language okay I'm I don't have an
objection to that represent
M you um this is the question to uh
director Courtney you said there are um
te members currently on the board you
didn't give me exact number but I in my
notes I have seven member board is it
seven member currently or going to a
seven member board I have counted nine
Mr chair uh represent M py followup
going from 9 to
3 with predominantly being Family and
Child
Welfare that would be a drastic cut I
would
think um I
get um representative
G the other piece I didn't speak to but
it it follows exactly what uh
representative ma maputi was just
referring
to is that like the dcyf uh position
like so a lot of these positions were um
agency or legislative kind of positions
and especially with the DCF U person
when you have people that this is part
of their job it limits when you're able
to meet and so then it can make it
scheduling really
difficult um and I do agree with the the
notion because DCF in my experience also
can have favorite guardian of items that
tend to side with them that they would
want to um see get appointed and what
have you or you know it it it could skew
things and then I mean I personally
would love to be on that as a
legislative appointee and yet there's a
lot of things I'd love to do I don't
know how much time I have and um yeah I
just these are advisory boards I think
part of it is that when it was a
regulatory board or a statutory board
having a lot of those on there made some
sense but I can see where um eliminating
some of those and then the judicial Appo
appointees I mean I don't know I you can
probably speak better to that than I can
about whether they need to be there I I
think because it's not regulatory you
certainly as taking over a lot of these
responsibilities can reach out to any
one of these people and get information
as you need it is that
correct yes that's
correct so um one for director Courtney
um so this board is going to act as an
advisor to
oplc and I guess the the question
is do you see
um right now if we go through this it'
be three one would be uh representing
the Supreme Court one would be the casa
uh
person um and one would be if we make
the change somebody who's an active
Guardian lium who's not part of Casa um
does that do you think that was is a
good mix to provide the advice needed is
there somebody an addition or
different you know because you you you
weren't express some weren't sure about
the the one pointed by the Supreme Court
or I I I think that's uh sufficient for
us to work with I mean I think to
represent of ghouls point I can always
reach out to DCF to get their input or
the HHS commissioner and or other
judicial you know the judicial Council
we do speak on other things so I think I
think that's sufficient for us to get
the expertise needed again what these
boards are doing is pretty limited it's
really just establishing the
requirements to get certified
um and I don't think we need I don't
think we need much more than what's in
there or more than what's in there just
a moment represent G are you do you
agree I mean having with the change you
wanted to the guardian of liem one is
are you comfortable with this I feel
like that's a balanced
representation and yeah I'm comfortable
with it and I feel like with this
because of the nature of the change of
the duties from regulatory to advisory I
think it gives her a good Advisory Group
they can look at complaints that come in
you've got a balanced view looking at
that and then um you can reach out for
advice from anybody I'm comfortable with
it thank you Mr okay and do you still
have a question represent
mapy yeah I I just still feel that
narrowing it and yes uh director
Courtney can reach out but it's not
anywhere required for you to do that
right you can make a decision on that
particular thing to say I don't need to
I have the expertise so they again I'm
looking at the checks and balances are
we shifting responsibility from one to
another and not overlooking so are there
particular members that are being
removed that you think should be back on
or is it just the total number or I I
would like to see a
representation from the dcyf or the
parent group that could have at least
five member board could give you that
flexibility these are three core people
that we need to get and the other two
can be an offsetting balancing to hold
checks and balances okay and to my thank
you and to director
Courtney um were there problems um
finding it's got two let say let's say
we went
to adding back in the DCF person
although I have questions about this
cast thing but Casey but and then add
let's say um one one member I'll get to
one member of the general public were
there problems in the past with finding
members of the general public who uh
meet these you know what what was in the
in statute now actually yeah no I think
if you eliminate the legislative
positions you're probably going to solve
most of the Quorum problems and the
executive director of the New Hampshire
judicial councel we already have
somebody who's being appointed by the
Supreme
Court so um I'm
not okay and I have a question then if
we were to put back in one member
representative DCF or Casey Family
Services or another child protective
agency um appointed by the governor but
I mean it it seems to imply Casey's an
agency of the government which or state
agency which are they no no I don't
think so I'm assuming they're not no
they they do contract with the state but
they're I I would probably limit it to
DCF
okay um just or yeah what's it I get get
to
protction
answer I just don't have too many
threats so case service operating
Foundation ring the for frost yeah
right so do we have
I we were just discussing that if he
left the um if he eliminated their
reference to Casey Family Services but
but cap the reference to another Child
Protection Agency in the state that
could be some catchall language in the
event that you know DC have changes his
name or what you know what have
you I'm I'm not I'm just still in I'm
I'm exploring something here and I I
intend to get back to you and whoever
else um but I think Bailey um okay and
then
um there's you know appointed by the
governor if we does it going back to
that would that make sense for if we
keep this one so so if it is a member of
DCF you you don't necessarily need an
appointment um if it's an Advisory Board
you I what I would say is probably the
director of the division of uh children
Youth and families or
designate okay all right we'll we'll
come back to this first uh
representative Bailey's had a question
pending and then representative goul did
I well earlier on in all the discussion
we' had it sounded as if Guardian this
is a licensed Guardian ad lims and they
were supposed to be the middle party the
parents were on one side and dcyf was on
the other and this is the middle party
licensing them what the hell does DCF
have to do with that they're one of the
opponents rather opposed of the middle
party unless you can find some way to
put in parents we do if you look at the
language starting in line 12 on p on 12
line 12 on page 12 there was U members
of the public and if certainly if we had
DCF back in we'd have to add at least
one of these back in yeah I agree with
that thank you representative gold so um
one of my points was going to be the
public member if we go this route should
be it should be stipulated that they're
parent if you look at it at the language
that struck out but isn't um it's a
public member representing the interest
of those individuals receiving the
services the guardian liem appointed by
the governor and then there's what they
can't be I mean they can't have been
currently or be Guardian Liam or spouse
or they can't have a material financial
interest in Guardian items or attacked
or actively directed directly related to
their services including the
representation the board or its pres
okay so you can look at that language
and see if you're happy with the current
standat okay just I just was mentioning
that more
importantly I'm not sure CA is from
Casey Family Services no they're
different different different yeah so
where where is Casey Family Services
referenced in here it it's on uh line
eight at the end with the dzf yeah it's
or okay wait minute line eight one
representing the division of children
youth and families or Casey Family
Services or another Child Protection
Agency in the state okay so
Casey they do a lot of like foster care
stuff yeah so that would be
[Music]
um so you could do I wonder if that's
what the focus is that professionals
working with foster children so those
are children who really are relying on
their Guardian I'd light them really
relying the parents really aren't there
to advocate for them like um like a
child that's still placed with their
family so should should we should the
language say that a professional agency
representing foster parents and just the
one last point before we move on would
be um and and representative maputi
brought this up dcyf is so stretched
stretched with their responsibilities
that I want to make sure before we add
them back in take them out all of that
that we know what their position would
be on this just yeah and to that um
given the current makeup of the board
right now is that person uh from DCF or
some other group Casey or some other
there is somebody who represents DCF
they but they're okay they work for DCF
I don't know what represent means I
don't know if they currently were
[Music]
um I'd have to check I don't know that
they currently work for DCF I know that
they represent DCF okay represent Brown
then uh M py thank you Mr chair so yes
it's it's going to be DCF or Casey or
and this is the semantics thing another
Child Protection Agency in the state I
don't think there is another the Child
Protection Agency in the state what
other than
DCF I know Easter seal was designated
under that category and they may still
be but are they are they actually an
agency of the state yeah they're part of
state that have to be part of state
government under some director no they
have a c it's complicated but they
they're categorized as a Child
Protection Agency it's wider it it was
back it was a yeah the language doesn't
say that they are a State Child
Protection Agency it says Child
Protection Agency in the state so they
could be eligible either Casey we could
take Casey out of you could take them
out and just leave another in this so
they' be eligible or this one she
mentioned could be or okay I know
traditionally do you know has it
generally been somebody from DCF yes it
is currently somebody from DCF okay and
then follow representative yeah followup
so I I I really need to do this for my
predecessor to this position that I am
in The Honorable Ned Gordon who was here
former Senator and former representative
and former judge in New
Hampshire um was opposed to this as you
remember quite
vehemently um what was he opposed to uh
specifically he said the board was
useful because back before the board
existed there was about 25 gal's that
were never trained or qualified in any
way whatsoever and there was no
repercussions of training now because
the board exists there is training and
standards uh that that he he said was a
a good process um he said most of the
seven members are involved in the gal
process in one way or another which
makes sense he also had issues with the
purpose of reducing work fee barriers
language which we have addressed I
believe um he did
say and and maybe oplc could follow up
that there's currently 20 complaints
going back to February I think you
talked about this that day director
Courtney
and that oplc had no answer to those
complaints at least that's my cryptic
notes here um and now because there
three members only I think his if I'm
remembering his his thought was if
there's that many complaints the three
members wouldn't be able to manage that
but they wouldn't director Courtney yeah
yeah I appreciate the opportunity to
respond to that um first of all this
board has met twice um in the last year
I believe and so that's a significant
issue with respect to the complaints
they have something that's somewhat
unique in their statute which is that if
we receive a complaint and it's about a
guardian ad item in a current Child
Protection case the board can't
investigate or do anything with the case
until the family court dispositions the
case and so that is why these cases
aren't moving forward now I understand
from a policy standpoint right because
in these cases you may have people that
are motivated to file complaints um I
get but at the same time it does extend
the process for us to be able to review
the complaints and um and because we
limit the ability because the board is
the adjudicating body we limit the
ability of the board to understand where
every case is in the process you know we
give them general information but we
don't want to give them specific
information so that could be a source of
the
misunderstanding followup follow up
since I'm I'm talking about the
honorable Ned Gord and we might as well
go through that list
um he did say now that if this will be
an Advisory Board what does that change
in the role and I think we've talked
about this nauseum this morning he's not
sure what an Advisory Board would do uh
only he thought only if oplc came to
them to ask for Rural review but I I
think we've beaten this to death this
morning but just for the sake of
addressing it on online here well yeah I
think we Tre our ADV boards very similar
I mean the same as regular independent
regulatory bodies um but there is that
aspect of State supervision so we would
expect them to hold meetings and do the
things that other boards do um reviewing
rules but also answering um questions
that require expert consultation
reviewing um reviewing reports of
investigation and then holding hearings
one last followup on that follow and
a a another representative on Edna asked
the question of uh Mr
Gordon how would the Advisory Board
improve what is happening because that
member said he had no confidence in oplc
was the
quote um and because oplc picks The
Advisory board members as that a problem
and Mr Gordon said he thought that was a
problem I'm just it hasn't been a
problem from my perspective but of
course that's me saying that um you know
I take issue with the not having
confidence you know with a board that
meets twice a year uh it's hard to know
you don't have a knowledge base to be
able to make that opinion would be my my
answer to that that's all thank you just
a a follow up on on that whole thing so
is the
backlog and dealing with complaints um
all are largely due to the fact that
they're tied up in court so you can't
proceed correct and where's the stat is
that Statute in here or is it under
somewhere else it I it is in their G
statute which is what in this is it
dealt with in this amendment or is it
somewhere
else we're going to take a look I don't
think I didn't notice I didn't see it in
this amendment but I wasn't as careful
with this all right representative
mipi thank you Mr chair uh couple of
things one is Casey Family Services is a
foundation sponsored private agency
provided child welfare services in New
England and Baltimore it focuses on
lifelong Family Practice model to
connect children and fostter care to
enduring families so that's the fostter
care aspect of it that dcyf deals with
both fostter care and reuniting with the
family members that's just the clar
ification and I think keeping that KC
Family Services will serve that third
group of
children that are in foster care
long-term foster care so one one thing
which we kind of talked about um I'd
like to see your view on it
so we could take Casey Family Service as
the explicit reference out leave in or
another child protective agency in the
state and Casey someone from Casey would
be eligible as well as maybe some other
one she mentioned so I wonder if you be
okay with that or does it specifically
have to be
Casey from having been in the field
Easter seal is used yes they are a
provider for different you know I'm not
suggesting them specifically but I don't
I don't know if there are any others but
to not I mean we've it hasn't been a
problem but I've seen elsewhere in
statute where you name a particular
organization ation and they they could
change their name or cease to exist and
then you got a promin statute that's
what I'm thinking I would like to see
Child Protective Services or if that
encompasses
both foster care because that's a whole
different group of kids that foster care
versus
reunification uh family
so that that that's a big issue in terms
of so you prefer leaving Casey in there
names I I don't know of any other which
provides okay I'm not my my issue is not
I don't know anything about them and
they may be wonderful I hope they are I
just I have an issue leaving name
particular uh you know groups by name in
here which is led to problem um but
maybe there there won't be a problem
yeah so that one I just wanted to uh let
you know and my other thing was going
back to my notes just before net Gordon
was another private practitioner also on
New Hampshire board Vicky Irvin who
opposed this with the same caveat in
terms of reducing the number of board
members and also the timeliness of
response from the board and the
oplc that
was uh that was very similar to what uh
net Gordon point of order there Mr Mr
Speaker I I had Nikki irin as
acupuncturist H I had Vicky Vicky Irwin
as an acupuncturist not about the g
board I don't she is on the acupuncture
board right so that's a different topic
that's my mistake I wrote it down as
this one okay so going back to the board
I think putting the three respon all the
responsibility to three board members we
are looking at children and the welfare
of the children and the future so I
would
feel adding DCF or similar board and a
parent or even somebody who has gone
through the foster care and aged out and
is successful would be a wonderful
appointee for that board um Ju Just okay
representative Brown so if we keep it as
it exists which is in line 8 and line
nine which we're deleting P it page 12
line 8 and nine so it hasn't happened
yet but it could be that DCF would not
have a position on this board and it
could be someone for Casey Family
Services or Easter Seals or whatever and
no dcyf or some other CH Protection
Agency and is that are we good with that
with DCF having potentially not having
representation I'm good with that I am
too but eight and nine
says or DCF or casy family or any other
yes so they will represent that's the
way it is today it is the way it is
today okay but are we okay leaving DCF
potentially the oras mean DCF might not
have a seat right I I certainly am okay
um I think I'm seven go to seven uh so
three well from nine five well if we
took out B and C the Senate and the
house member right and I'd be okay
taking out well let's see so if we took
out those three at the
top um we so that the one from the
court um the uh the cassa uh person if
we put not the Casta or no I'm looking
at so this is on line six on page 12
yeah are you saying to take that out I
mean that's no no leave that in
no what cassa n cassa and Cassie family
Serv Cas no I'm talking about six and
seven right it says cassa we have to
keep cassa we keep down below Casey
Family Services is where we were going
to take the name out right so I I'm
going I what I'm saying is I'm listen
the ones that would be in there and then
potential additions yep so cassa we
leave in we have the we have the one
appointed by the Supreme Court y the
cassa one would be in there we're
talking about adding back in the DCF or
eight and nine right three and and we
can further discussion as whether case's
specifically listed or not um and then
we'd have uh the guardian M Lim person
that's four and then we would add back
in one member of The General public who
is a parent with the same language
that's in here unless we want to change
the language that's in statute think
representative ghoul wants it to state
that that person is a parent right yes
um okay but that that would be five
which is I'm a good number so um just
kind of a procedural
thing Mr chair going back to this
instead of saying one member eight and
nine one member representing the
division of Children
dcyf
and or Casey family or any other instead
of doing one member can we do two two
two issu I that way it gives you DCF as
well as casy I don't I I wouldn't be
comfortable with that and if we do that
to make it odd we'd have to add somebody
else maybe two members of the public or
something we have to stay odd because so
there's not
ties um representative
Bailey
I think we began with a large board that
really met and had Quorum problems and I
think this is an inverse relationship
that the more people we add the more we
get back to the original
problem agreed although we're looking at
going from three to five and instead of
the original nine nine so it would be
almost half of even with this addition
it' be around half of what it
was you know I I take a point and I and
I think that m to chair yeah if we if we
go to five then you know our our our
former legislator and judge that that
might assade some of his concerns about
it going to three yeah W okay um and and
can I just thank you Mr chair that uh in
line 8 and nine if we just remove
everything and say A Child Protection
Agency one one member who represents a
Child Protection Agency in the state I
think that way that gives the choice and
and the freedom and honestly for a lot
of parents just taking out
DCF takes away a lot of The Angst and
the
you and where's the public one the
public one would be uh the part that
struck out we put back in line 12
through um
18 yeah well well so here I know you
want the
parent um I think this stuff about not a
conflict and not so here here's what I'd
suggest we're talking about making a lot
of changes here I have some notes I'm
not sure they're entirely coherent um
would someone be willing to take on the
job of uh given what we've
said including that last good
suggestion to um write up language of
what they think we kind of agreed to and
then we meet again you know and email it
out to members subcommittee we meet
again we can discuss and see if you know
if we're all okay with it and it
represents what we think we've been
discussing and then we can vote on that
because I don't think we're we're not
have something clear enough to vote on
at this point so I'd be willing to take
a copy of your notes and with my notes
draft something distribute it get
feedback with other people's
notes and then have a right we need to
be a little careful on the 911a of
having a meeting that's not in the
public so I think it's fine if you come
up with a proposal and write it up and
send it out to all of us but we do not
discuss it together until a meeting
that's kind of my understanding
one-on-one conversation to yeah and and
the other thing is there are uh
exceptions for caucus so you could I
think you could speak with represent M
I'm not sure we could discuss it
ourselves as odd as that might seem I I
did read over um we got extensive notes
on this this morning that I read over
and from Lucy Weber and I do believe
that just to uh straighten out the
language in a homework assignment that
we then will discuss fully and openly
public so if if any of us thinks if any
of us thinks that what you wrote up
differs from what they thought they
heard here then that's a kind of a
technical thing they could reply to
everybody but not about if we decide
from a policy standpoint we don't like
it correct okay I'm okay with that
everybody needs to be
careful uh representative Brown sure um
that being a selectman and having this
that we're told reply all constitutes a
meeting I'm not sure if that's correct
that's my understanding of what I'm
told and therefore would have to be
noticed and if you reply all then you're
actually having a meeting so we could
reply if you if you think that there's a
technical problem or that you think
representative g m misunder understood
things differently than you in a
technical sense or whatever that's fine
um but yeah we can't be getting into
policy discussions on email yeah so
exactly I would respond that reply don't
use reply all is a really good cover
your butt technique to not get in
trouble but we can do it oneon-one and
we're only talking about did I miss a
notation of a change that someone else
heard yeah the email to everybody to try
and schedule a meeting I think is a
different story okay so there is a a
bunch more to this we're we're it goes
up to page 20 and we're on page 12 so
the question is
um do we want to you know and I guess
I'm I'll ask uh either director Courtney
or Mr AER house the is there anything
beyond this point you know from uh uh
the
membership Mr chair just to tell you my
brain is you need to go okay I can't
doore then that's done um what what I
would suggest if everybody's okay with
it we'll meet um morning before session
that's this Thursday
is that okay sure 15 yeah is 9:00 am
okay to give us that way we'd have uh
we'd have three hours before we have to
break for lunch and then session does
anybody have a problem with that and if
you do we can meet at 10 or not at
all I will do my best to be there at 9:
um Mr chair and certainly I can catch up
if you start at 9: and I'm a few minutes
late I I'll do my best is 9
substantially better uh or well I I've
been 10 minutes late the last two times
so just go for it I'll get there as best
I can because I think I mean for the
rest of this I think it's going to be
important to have you there all right
especially for the rest of this section
okay giv your experience all right let
let let's say 9:30 and I'll definitely
be there know the Fus is going to be
that
day is there going to be a concus 12
there is you folks have
said which means we would need to break
by you know at least a quarter or
12 um I'll be a big girl and get there
by 9: if I tell my husband he'll start
at 5: pushing me are seriously 9 9: A.M
is okay he's busy
watching right he's seeing you he's Comm
if he is he's watching you committing
morning uh session starts at 1 pm on
Thursday which is the
15th yeah and the first part of the I
would I would I would never suggest
anyone miss any of the governor's speech
course but officially we probably
shouldn't run through into that although
um but uh no disrespect to the governor
it's just I'm not big on
speeches um okay so that's what we'll do
we will we will meet at 9: we will break
you know uh 11:30ish I guess meeting
here meeting here well I'm going to send
the request in to our assistant Carrie
Morris and she will email out the notice
because it could be something else is
scheduled we're going to beet somewhere
probably in the lob but I can't
guarantee it's here I bring myop
12 putting in it is up to you I I I have
enough trouble managing my own stuff so
I'll we bet you um anyway I'm going to
close the subcommittee work session on
House Bill 1271 thank you to everyone
for working on this um D nuts I have a
no you're not driving me nuts I I think
I think I may have a I may have a
personal preference to not have
individual bills that deal with so many
things even if they are related complely
but um that's another matter thank
thanks thank you folks for in here and
uh we'll see you again I think th could
be a long day thank you I hope you do as
well thank you both and no answering my
email over the weekend
no I don't know if I'll send you any but
send
me I'm gonna send you the amend yes
because I I I personally have to make
some decisions on that obviously right
away I'll send it to I appreciate it
that's on some other bill yeah okay it's
on my bill about veteran
licensing which is well you heard
it you heard it when I was in fishing
game and I didn't know it was being
heard
oh